programming throwdown episode 167 desktop user interfaces take it away patrick as a true nerd figured out a way to make even the things I never thought I would do nerdy. So I guess I should, this sounds like a brag, like true nerd. I don't know what that means. I'm not gatekeeping. Everyone could be a nerd. If you're listening to the show, you're a nerd. Yeah, that's right. You're all honorary nerds, even if you just started. I did some amount of physical fitness stuff, you know, in high school, be on some sports teams. And then it sort of just languished when I became an adult. I know a lot of people like play pickup basketball and stuff, which is great. What sports did you play? I played basketball,
but I was never very good at it, to be honest. Yeah, same here. I played basketball. And despite being very tall, I was also absolutely terrible at basketball like it's the was that the hundred thousand hour ten thousand hour thing i just wasn't willing to put in the like i would go to practices but i never like played on the weekends or it wasn't it wasn't a passion yeah i mean my thing was i was and i realize this now watching my kids play sports like i just don't want to touch anybody else physically touch anybody else. And so I would see like, how could I play,
you know, this sport, whether it's basketball or soccer or whatever, in a way where like, I don't have to even inadvertently like touch anybody ever. And, uh, and of course you just can't,
can't really play most sports that way. I ended up finding my niche in volleyball, but every other sport pretty much can't work that way. ended up finding my niche in volleyball but every other okay all right pretty much can't work that way so i uh this all started i guess for a variety of reasons a family of member member of mine uh started jogging running um a while ago like years and years ago now i was like man okay that's good um so i was visiting with them recently and then it was like kind of feeling bad they were getting up to go for their morning run and i was like enjoy i'm gonna just sit here on my phone um and then then i was uh you don't have you know you get these smart watches i have you have an apple
watch or whatever um but i think other ones do the same thing and so it gives you this estimate of your body's like aerobic capacity so-called vo2 max i don't know that much about it you actually get it measured you go to a you know gym and they give you like a face mask that you have to wear and it measures like oxygen and carbon dioxide i don't know something like that while running on a treadmill and it has to do with your body's like ability to process and you know handle high amounts of physical activity or whatever so so they estimate it on a variety of other factors that are correlated with it and they give you the score and it says your cardio fitness is below average. Now, I'm not like the healthiest person. I'm not going to lie. But like in general, you know, I like to consider
myself healthy-ish. I mean, it hurts when you see that, you know, it hurts. So I have a scale that tells me my body fat is not what it should be and a watch that tells me my cardio fitness so all this piled up to say okay i'm gonna do something about this i'm i'm getting up in age uh you know it's not gonna get any better right so i was like i'm gonna start running but of course it's not you can't just run like oh i have tennis shoes i'm gonna no no no no no like that was not how i approached it so i gotta like figure out i'm gonna do a program oh there's an app oh there's an app is gonna tell me exactly what i have to run each day uh and like go up by a set amount you know each week so this amount of run followed by walk run walk and then each
week it's gonna get better and then you'll be able to run a 5k which is sort of like the shortest distance that has common races you can run like a mile or 100 yard dash or whatever but like as an adult i don't know how you go find a place where you run 100 yard dash or 100 meter dash. But 5k's are pretty common. You can just Google it. There's probably one in your city every week, certain times of the year, probably. So I was going to like, okay, I'm gonna run a 5k. Then I realized, oh, my watch can give me all these running metrics. And then not only like per run, can you find stuff like how many times your feet are moving per minute? And there's an optimal range that you should be in for that.
And cues to make sure your like body is biomechanically efficient and studies to back that up. But then aggregating them across days. What is your training load like? Are you getting enough rest? What is the math behind it? Oh, there's this set of people has a study. This other set of people has a study. They have different ways of calculating.
You can bounce back and forth. And then you get into the traditional tech stuff. Everyone tries to lock your data up. So then you have all these ways of like exporting it to like more open source platforms or cross platform stuff or just more free platforms. And there's like, oh, are you in the Apple ecosystem or the Garmin ecosystem or the Polar ecosystem or the Kuros ecosystem? And there's like all this lock-in.
And it's just endlessly fascinating that people have. So I was talking to this family member of mine and sort of saying, oh, you know, I'm doing this. So I run on my Apple Watch, but I instantly grab all the data and push it up to this other platform. It's called Runalyze. Runalyze just runs this like free agnostic input source you know running all these algorithms on whatever it comes from um maybe they'll eventually charge they're not really open source but it's sort of at least free for now and so i just grab all my data and put up there and he's like yeah but i've been using and he's using garmin or whatever i've been using
garmin for like 11 years all my data is there and i'm just like locked in because of all this history of run so um you know so i so I've been running still pretty early. Yeah, what's the effect? Like, did you, like, is the data helping you along? So it's keeping me engaged. I will say like, it's like the base level metrics that are improving. So like resting heart rate is trending down.
That's good. This VO2 max estimated is ticking up. I'm still below average. But I've been doing it sort of eight weeks. And, you know, it's just, I guess. So the thing that is encouraging, well, discouraging, but encouraging is some of them will give you like how ready you are to run a marathon. And then it tells me 3%.
And so I'm like, okay, well, clearly there's headroom here. And so I find it very encouraging to be able to look at a description of all this stuff. People say that you got to write it down. Write down your metrics tracking because you're more likely to stick with it. Writing it down sounds very tedious. So instead, you just shove it all up in the cloud and you get a bunch of graphs that show you just how slow you actually are uh and then you you know so this uh once you sort of get into it you start seeing times of like professional elite racers like people who do it as a career in the olympics or whatever and you see their time compared to your time and the interesting
thing is like if you were to play basketball and say a professional basketball player was going to play basketball, you're not really playing the same game. The strategies, dunking, the kinds of three-pointers they do, it's clear you're not doing the same thing. Running is not like that. When Ilyad Chogy runs a marathon at world record pace and you run a marathon at abysmal pace, you roughly look like you're doing the same thing. Like the body mechanics look similar. Like if you don't have a context, the speed could even look the same. It's not. But you know, it's sort of, you're just, they're doing the same thing as you just like faster. And so there's almost this like motivation. You don't have to learn a new skill. You just have to do more of it. Like, oh, I just have to get a
little faster, a little faster. And of course there's some power law distribution right like eventually moving down a minute is incredibly hard versus for me moving down a minute and pace is trivial but you know it doesn't you get diminishing returns there but there's this the pros and me do the same thing we just go and run and so it's sort of been interesting and motivating and the metrics seeing you know this direct one-to-one comparison i run a mile and x minutes they run a mile and y minutes versus you can't compare yourself to you know a football player or soccer player or basketball player like they do what and you do why in a number to number comparison i don't know of
a number to do that yeah that makes that makes sense. Um, yeah, because there's basically an arms race, you know, like there's a whole bunch of strategies that might work at the high school level, but then by college, everyone's learned those strategies, you know, in basketball or something. And so you have to, you have to do something different. Um, but, uh, yeah, that's awesome. I mean, the most I've ever done in that is, uh, I do have a, uh, Fitbit that keeps track of my heart rate and I try to keep my heart rate in a certain zone. So if it's not in that zone, then I'll slow down or even walk and I'll just try and keep it at that number.
Um, but yeah, I mean, that's just scratching the surface. Yeah. It's interesting if you really dive in and then we'll leave this alone. But even the various, why does that zone training work? What are the ways of picking the range? How do you tell? And then there's, you know, the sort of how you feel way of tracking it. There's like a mathematical formula to track it.
And then there's the actual like getting at, I go run on a treadmill and prick my finger and measure like how much of various hormones and lactate are in my blood. And it tells you like, you know, your various thresholds. So it's kind of an interesting range of, you know, philosophies for ultimately, but just amounts to like going and running, which you've been doing for however old you are, minus, you know, three or four years, I guess, we've all been running for years and years and years. But to kind of try to hone it is uh it's a kind of another endeavor yeah i had a buddy who would run on the treadmill and he was extremely athletic and he'd run a treadmill at high velocity and um and then also play final fantasy 7 and try to like optimize it at the same time
like while he's running and i remember one time thinking yeah this is probably what like a human like this is probably what the matrix looks like you know like your your brain power and your physical power are just being kind of like maximally exerted uh on this station all right well with that we'll go to uh news of the show news of the show so uh yeah both of my news are foul and you know obviously folks know we don't swear on the show we've never sworn on the show uh at least i don't think we've literally never sworn on the show but you know sometimes do, we bleep it out. But I just happened to, just coincidentally, I have two somewhat foul news articles.
I'll do my first one. Now, I'll give a bit of backstory to this. So I'm always trying to create different experiences, games and toys and stuff like that. And so I wanted to make, and it sounds kind of silly but but hear me out i wanted to make a uh engineering manager simulator or maybe just more generic like a manager simulator and so you would mediate conflicts with people and you'd have to kind of place bets on different areas and and just the parts that are kind of strategically fun about being a manager i wanted to just distill that down and make manager simulator and so i wanted chat gbt to be you know kind of a big part of this where you know there would be discussions among different chat gbt agents
who have been given different different goals and you know you would you would you know see all this information and all this intra-office diplomacy. And ChatGPT is extremely strict on negativity. I even tried something like write a mean letter to this person about some project that they messed up. And ChatGPT is like, I'm sorry, I can't write mean things or I will not disparage anyone. And it was just like, I literally couldn't finagle, even like a polite but direct negative message.
who have been given different different goals and you know you would you would you know see all this information and all this intra-office diplomacy. And ChatGPT is extremely strict on negativity. I even tried something like write a mean letter to this person about some project that they messed up. And ChatGPT is like, I's sorry, I can't write mean things or I will not disparage anyone. And it was just like, I literally couldn't finagle, even like a polite but direct negative message.
And I don't know, maybe it's like a situation that's in flux. But when I went to ChatGP a few weeks ago, or a week ago, like I literally couldn't get it to do it. As three laws of robotics here. That's right. Human. And so when when I'm and this is speaks a little bit to my psyche, when someone tells me or some system tells me I can't do something i immediately think there's a business opportunity here like like if you can't do something then uh maybe there's some value there and the only way you're going to extract it is by somehow subverting the system and and so that
might take an idea from being like uh the pet rock idea where literally anyone could do it to an idea where like maybe only you could do it. And so there's a chance to be like a real innovator. So I started poking around and I found something called the unholy LLM on Hugging Face. And so this is a Lama 2 model. So Lama 2 is a large language model that comes from facebook so it started out as that but then it's been fine-tuned it's been trained on i actually don't even know what it's been trained on but whatever it is it's it's completely uncensored i don't think it's been trained on like purposely the worst parts of the internet or anything um and the reason i i
don't think that is because you know i started off you know just saying like uh you know tell me a joke about about this this company or tell me a joke about elon musk or you know tell me 10 books i should read and i got all like very normal answers um but if you tell it to write a nasty letter it will write a nasty letter and it will drop f-bombs it will do everything and it is actually hilarious um i've been showing off to uh um we had some family friends in town uh and i was showing them um you know and then we were all getting a really big kick out of it. Um, and I guess like kind of two takeaways, one, um, you know, yeah, it is actually really hard to say kind of anything negative on any of these or, you know, generative AI things. Uh, but two, um, you can almost trivially download these. I was running it on my laptop cpu uh the laptop has it's a macbook
but it's too old and so i couldn't use the metal accelerator uh whatever that is so so it's literally running on on the cpu and it was still able to generate like several tokens per second and so you ask a question and you get an answer in 10 15 seconds um um and this is with a 13 billion parameter model so um overall i was just incredibly impressed with how far the open source has gotten um there's a hugging face has a leaderboard which is how i found this unholy model i basically i was going down the leaderboard it's like you know chat gbt metas llama i know both of those are extremely strict um you know and then there was a few others i think you have to pay for or i just didn't know much about and then this one came up i was like all
right let's do it um so so yeah it was a really fun experience uh you know again you know you shouldn't spend a whole bunch of time doing rude things. But now if I want to have this sort of intra-office conflict among these AI agents, I could do it without any worry of the system just becoming unplayable.
Yeah, I guess the one level more morality problem is you could end up with an AI or LLM that goes from just sort of hilariously in context dropping F-bombs to something that's actually traumatic sounding or describing a really bad scene or something that... Uncensored, it's not like a binary thing like you're either censored or uncensored i guess it can be but there's like it's like a gradient and you could go really really far down like somehow it actually learned something about you and then it's saying stuff about you personally and like it sort of jumps the boundary breaks the third wall whatever and like you run into people just really really turned off or upset or even like, you know, someone damaged or, you know, really messed up by this thing.
So I hear you. But I also could see why, you know, businesses don't want... That's always what happens. You know, these get unleashed and then someone convinces it to say something really bad or, you know, something that's socially considered a very bad faux pas to talk about. And, uh, you know, write an article, Oh, this is, this is the worst thing ever. But yeah, I mean, there was one that I skipped over, which was, I can't remember the name. I was trying to look it up just now, but it said it was literally trained on this forum called 4chan. And I was like, okay, I know enough. I know what that word means that I'm going to skip this one. And so, yeah, I think you're right. I think that there's a spectrum here.
You know, I literally wanted to write a professional letter where one employee felt like another one should get fired in my game. And I couldn't do that. And then there's, you know, as said there's there's many many layers to that onion and yeah i would also recommend people just you know for your own insanity just yeah don't don't don't go down that rabbit hole but but you know if you want something if you if you even for my you know if folks remember i released this generativefiction.com i released this uh this text adventure with uh with chat gpt where you know as you meet different npcs you ask them questions and chat gpt generates answers i was i was just looking at some of the stats that i was collecting on that and a significant
percentage of people's questions were blocked and you know almost none of those questions were foul like somebody asked uh one of these in-game characters um you know like like uh have you ever been on a cruise ship that sank so the premise of the story is you're on a cruise ship and uh you know it's it's there's a there's like a murder on the cruise ship and it's a murder mystery um and so someone asked you have you ever been on a cruise ship that sank to one of the NPCs? And ChatGBT blocked that question. So it is very strict. But yeah, also don't go down that rabbit hole too far.
Don't look into the black mirror or whatever. Look into the abyss. Yeah, I think I said break the third wall, but I was thinking break the fourth wall. I don't know. I don't understand the indexing scheme. Zero versus one indexing, we'll call it. You don't know what LLM thought about that metaphor. No, no, no, no, I don't.
I really don't. All right, so my next article is from a blog from a person who was dealing with an incident. This is on the Blameless blog. I've never read it before. We'll have a link in the show notes. But this concept was pretty interesting. The story itself was, I feel like, full of a few mistakes in dealing with this incident. But this reverse red herring was kind of interesting. So most folks know what a red herring is. And if you're debugging something or a problem goes and someone just gets really fixated on this
thing that just feels very, very obvious, but it turns out to be a red herring, it's just not worth considering. You should just move on and you're really wasting your time. And so the reverse red herring is opposite. It's something that actually probably should be standing out, but you kind of skip it or ignore it, or for some reason you discount it and you don't spend enough time looking at it. You proceed through your processing of information, your incidents, trying to do an analysis of what's going on. And then someone has an idea, wait a minute, what about that thing we stopped considering? And all of a sudden, it just bubbles right back up to the top again. And so I thought that was a sort of interesting phenomenon to name something reverse red herring uh sort of an interesting
i guess almost a double negative it just means interesting but it's been discounted for some reason uh yeah the one i could think of that came up recently was um we had some code where there had accidentally been a new line inserted, but the code still ran. And so the second part of that line was, if you just look at it in isolation, it basically does nothing. It's kind of like saying zero or something. So you could put a zero semicolon in C++, it just won't do anything. I think so. But, um,
um, but yeah, this was one of those, but actually ended up being a really serious issue because that, that, that second part of that first line was meant to do something really important. Yeah.
Yeah. And it would be in this case, just to finish off the story, I guess they had rolled out a new binary to their an endpoint and the sort of circumstances were that the effect was it looked like everybody else was uh had gotten a sort of like pad configuration was ddossing their service um and in actuality it was that their new deployment had a bug in it that was giving a bad response, which was... And then the clients were said, if you get a bad response,
basically turn around and ask again because something as bad as happening. So they were DDoSing themselves. And originally, they were like, oh, no, it can't be this new deployment. This is not how it would manifest itself. And actually, it was. And it feels like a bad deployment.
You just rolled something out and then everything bad happens. That feels like it should probably bad deployment like you just rolled something out and then everything bad happens that feels like it should probably be the first thing you consider but they tossed it out as a red herring because they thought they had done it due diligence but uh they hadn't and it could it could have been coincidental in this case it wasn't very cool um my second article is, and again, it has a cuss word in it, so I'm going to rephrase this. It's the hoopification of TikTok. But the important thing is actually the subtitle, which says, How Exactly Platforms Die. This is an amazing article.
It really, you know, it's one of these things that I've always kind of felt, but I haven't really seen anyone put it in writing. And this person puts it in writing extremely eloquently. Basically, the thesis here is, and they use Amazon, I think these Instagram and these TikTok as examples. I'm not actually on Instagram or TikTok. Are you on Instagram, Patrick? I think I have an account. I think a lot of these, I have an account and that's about the extent of my being on. Okay. Um, so the, what they talk about here, which I've definitely seen is, is, you know, in the beginning, you're trying to spin up this platform. So you have this cold start
problem, you know, like how do you get good content on TikTok? How do you get the first hundred people on TikTok? And so what they do is they set up a bunch of really friendly deals and they really focus on content creation. They give great tools. They do rev share with content creators. They get famous content creators on and they give them money up front, et cetera, et cetera. And so it becomes a great place for content creators. So they go there. A lot of these platforms, I mean, Amazon is notable for this. You know, if you're exclusive on Amazon, you know, they would they would actually subsidize your your content so you could actually sell you know a beach ball on amazon for 14
dollars because for every beach ball you sell amazon will literally give you an extra dollar so they were running this is in the 90s amazon was running everything at a huge loss um and all of it was in service of creators so a bunch of creators flock to the platform sign all sorts of exclusivity deals um and then the platform kind of gets the creators and they say look like we kind of have these people now so now you know we could just kind of exploit them and let's focus on um um right? And so Amazon now says, okay, you know, forget about creators, we have all the creators, let's focus on basically, you know, getting as many, you know, people to buy as many things as possible, or in the case of TikTok, get as many people to watch as many videos as possible, etc, etc. And so they go down that rabbit hole and at some point they get kind of a lion's share
of the people and that becomes saturated there's actually a third element which is the advertising so amazon if you look at it now they'll actually a lot of the search results are sponsored which is really weird if you think about it it's like someone's paying for the opportunity to sell you a beach ball, right? It's kind of weird. And whether you buy it or not, that person's out that money. This is really the opposite of what it was when it started where sort of Amazon paying the beach ball company and subsidizing their products. Now, the beach ball company has to subsidize Amazon to like, you know, to make their beach ball show up at the top. And the thing about, you know, advertising, especially like in the case of Amazon, where there's not an advertiser, it's just Amazon, is you're you end up basically squeezing both of
those people. And, and you can just squeeze them as much as you, you know, as much as you're willing to tolerate them sort of leaving your platform. And so invariably, because of short-term thinking, platforms squeeze too hard, people leave, and then the platform becomes desolate. I mean, it hasn't happened in the case of Amazon, but with Instagram and TikTok, all the metrics are trending downward.
I thought it was amazing the way that this person really laid it out i think there's a ton of truth to it is it written by cory doctorow that's what it looks like uh yeah is that a famous person i have no idea who that is yes it's okay who is that like what are they known for oh they i mean they've written a lot of things they've written i think fiction books as well but they do a lot of writing and introspection of the tech industry. Oh, interesting.
Okay. Yeah, I'm not very good at... I probably should be better at when I read a really good article noting the author, but I haven't really... It's always been kind of a blind spot. He was the one who ran Boing Boing
for a long time, if you ever ended up on that site. Yeah. Yeah, I try not to attack social media because I don't participate. So I feel like it's an easy target for me to cast stones. But I think this cycle is very hard, right? You want to build something up.
How do you maintain it? It goes by a lot of names and a lot of cycles, but this is a very difficult trade-off. Like long-term metrics is what you want, right? How do you keep users engaged for one, two, three, four years? But by definition, those are very hard to actually know what a user is going to do two years from now when you're 90 days into a project.
And so you end up optimizing for results uh but whose results is uh i think that was an accurate arc of uh choosing who you're going to optimize for yeah totally uh i guess in a similar vein um there's been and not gonna you know sort to fully go into it, but there's been some controversy with Unity, which we've talked about on the show before, a game engine, and changing some of their pricing practices. And there's another game engine, Godot. And Godot is open source. So, of course, it doesn't have any costs associated with it, at least any monetary costs you have to pay out initially. And so a lot of people have been talking about, oh, now's the time you really should move to Godot. Godot's gotten a lot better.
You see a little bit the same thing with Blender. Blender's really come into its own despite being actually a very old project. But you see a lot of new stuff getting poured into Blender recently, or at least I have. It's become part of the zeitgeist and just really a mature product.
And so people were talking about, and then there was couple famous you know kind of like live streams of independent game developers porting their games from you know unity to godot and this you know start everyone got really excited um and so someone wrote an article that was sort of like you know basically that this is not true that there are some functions in inot around ray tracing. They're just really, really bad. And you should not move to Godot. Godot is not ready. It's not mature. It's not whatever.
And the, I guess, benevolent dictator for life, BDFL, this is like a commenter. Anyways, he runs the Sam Pruden, I guess is, I don't know that much about the Godot project. So if I'm messing this up, I apologize. But I guess he's the benevolent dictator for life of Godot. So he's sort of like the person in charge. And so he wrote a response to this person's article about, you know, Godot is not a replacement for unity. And actually, as weird as this sounds, the reason I bring it up here is for two reasons.
然后，我猜，终身仁慈独裁者，BDFL，这就像是个评论员。不管怎样，他运营着Sam Pruden，我猜是，我对Godot项目了解不多。所以如果我弄砸了，我道歉。但我猜他是Godot的终身仁慈独裁者。所以他有点像是负责人。因此，他针对这个人关于“Godot不能替代Unity”的文章写了一篇回应。实际上，听起来可能有点怪，我在这里提起这件事有两个原因。
It has almost nothing to do with any of the stuff I've talked about so far. And so the two reasons I think that this article is worth a link, you should check it out, is one, the way the diplomacy that Sam handles this response is incredible. So someone has basically penned an article, pointed out some flaws in a project he's worked on and put enormous amounts of time in. And he gives them every benefit of the doubt over and over again. Now, I don't know the person who wrote the first article. I don't know anything about Godot. But some analysis says, or even just a simple reading and looking at Sam's responses, it's very likely that they cherry picked some
它几乎与我到目前为止谈论的任何内容都没有关系。因此，我认为这篇文章值得分享并让你去看看的两个原因，一是萨姆处理这篇回应时表现出的外交手段令人难以置信。所以有人基本上写了一篇文章，指出了他参与过并投入了巨大精力的项目的一些缺陷，而他一次又一次地给予对方充分的信任。现在，我不认识写第一篇文章的人。我对Godot一无所知。但一些分析说，或者仅仅是简单阅读并查看萨姆的回应，极有可能是他们挑选了一些
worst case numbers, and then some other worst case stuff and then got like, you know, basically something that made Godot look very bad performance wise. But the diplomacy is Sam responding in a public manner, but being just very restrained and saying, look, maybe they just, you know, happen to pick an idiomatic case here where like, it's not actually the normal case most of our stuff doesn't fall to this problem but they are right this one thing for legacy reasons hasn't been refactored and does suffer performance problems so they give credit where credit is due that yes this is bad yes we should fix this give benefit of the doubt just so i guess like refreshing to
最坏情况下的数字，然后再挑了一些其他最坏情况下的东西，然后得到了一个（你知道的）基本上让Godot在性能方面看起来非常糟糕的结果。但这种外交手段体现在萨姆以公开的方式回应，同时又非常克制，他说，看，也许他们只是碰巧在这里挑选了一个惯例案例，就像，这其实不是我们大多数东西都会遇到的正常情况，但他们说得对，这一个东西由于历史遗留原因还没有被重构，确实存在性能问题。所以他该肯定的时候就肯定，是的，这很糟糕，是的，我们应该修复它，并且给予对方信任。这让人感觉...
read someone handle something without like saying it's my job to just flame out and scream at everyone and just tell them these people are stupid and our project is better and instead just handle it very gracefully. That's sort of thing one. It's going to be really dense. Thing two, it actually goes into a pretty awesome description
读到有人处理事情时，不是说“我的工作就是大发雷霆、对所有人尖叫，告诉这些人他们很愚蠢，我们的项目更好”，而是非常优雅地处理它，这真的让人耳目一新。这是第一点。这可能会非常深奥。第二点，它实际上对
of how if you want to write a core game engine, as an example, but you want hooks for a scripting language, so Godot has a scripting language, but it also has hooks for other languages, C++ or Python or whatever, and you want these hooks, you have to think a lot about how other bindings are going to call into your core library
如何编写核心游戏引擎（例如），同时又为脚本语言保留钩子（比如Godot有一种脚本语言，但它也有适用于其他语言的钩子，比如C++或Python等等），以及如果你想要这些钩子，你必须对其他绑定将如何调用你的核心库
and the languages it's developed in. And so there's a discussion about this. I called it ABI, Application Binary Interface, which is how actual, you know, parameters get pushed into a set of contiguous memory to be passed from one program, one part of the program to another, right? So in Python, you got to kind of set some specific bytes in a certain way so that you can pass it into Godot and then Godot knows what to do. And this is normally accomplished by some sort of API, right? Which is like the sort of human readable description of the function. Like this is a function that takes in an integer as a parameter. But of course, like once you sort of compile it, you don't actually need that anymore. As long as if your
以及它所开发的语言进行大量思考，进行了非常精彩的描述。因此，这里有一个关于这方面的讨论。我称之为ABI，即应用程序二进制接口，它是实际的（你知道的）参数如何被推入一组连续内存中以从程序的一个部分传递到另一部分的机制，对吧？所以在Python中，你必须以某种特定方式设置一些特定的字节，以便你可以将它们传递给Godot，然后Godot就知道该怎么做了。这通常是通过某种API来实现的，对吧？也就是对函数的某种人类可读的描述。就像这是一个将整数作为参数的函数的描述。但是当然，一旦你对其进行了编译，你其实就不再需要那个了。只要你的
assembly language puts an integer in the right spot, jumps to some other correct location of the program, and knows how to go grab that data that you put there, you don't need to know what the parameter names are. They're not used intrinsically by the program. And so there's a description that goes through that, which I just thought was actually really well done, pointing out something that you don't normally think about, which is they have some primitive types. And then what they tried to do, except in some edge cases, is make sure that all of their functions adhere to the same few types. So if you're writing a wrapper, you don't have to make arbitrary data structures. Instead, your data structures are composed of all of these primitive types. And then you, by composition, get a full featured API and sort of facilitate this wrapper thing. And then
汇编语言将一个整数放在正确的位置，跳转到程序的其他正确位置，并且知道如何去获取你放在那里的数据，你就不需要知道参数名称是什么。程序本身并不会使用它们。因此，文中对此进行了描述，我认为这实际上做得非常好，指出了一个你平时不会想到的事情，那就是他们有一些基本类型。然后他们试图做的是，除了某些边缘情况外，确保他们的所有函数都遵循相同的少数几种类型。因此，如果你正在编写一个包装器，你不必制作任意的数据结构。相反，你的数据结构是由所有这些基本类型组成的。然后，通过组合，你就可以获得一个功能齐全的API，并促进这种包装器的实现。然后
internally, they make sure that they sort of use those primitives as much as they can. So you don't have to do this unpacking, repacking, conversion, and the code just is sort of compiled away, right? It just becomes a no op that the data just flows. And it doesn't have to be parsed or, you know, are mangled in some way or unmangled. And so I just thought, actually, that was a very interesting read from a technical aspect of what someone building, in this case, it's a game engine, but any application where you're expecting people to interact with it from other languages. Just a really fascinating sort of read there.
在内部，他们确保尽可能多地使用这些基本类型。这样你就不必进行这种解包、重新打包、转换，代码就会被编译掉，对吧？它只是变成了一个空操作，数据直接流动。它不需要以某种方式被解析或（你知道的）乱码或恢复。所以我只是觉得，从构建者（在这个例子中是一个游戏引擎，但对于任何期望人们从其他语言与之交互的应用程序来说）的技术角度来看，这是一篇非常有趣的阅读材料。这真的是一种非常迷人的阅读体验。
I would encourage people, it's not super long, despite I probably spent more time talking about it, but definitely check it out. Very interesting. Yeah, so I think, you know, there's the Sam Pruden article and then there's a response from the Godot lead dev, which is linked to from that article.
我鼓励大家去看看，它不是很长，尽管我可能花在上面谈论的时间更多，但绝对值得一看。非常有趣。是的，所以我想，你知道的，有萨姆·普鲁登的文章，然后是Godot首席开发人员的回应，那篇文章里有链接指向它。
And I think a lot of the binding stuff, well, no, I think it's just one click away. So you want to read what Sam wrote and then check out the response. And in the response, there's code samples, and they dive in really deep on this. You're right. I'm sorry. Yeah, so I messed that up.
而且我觉得关于绑定的很多内容，哦不，我觉得只需点击一下即可。所以你想阅读萨姆写的东西，然后查看回应。在回应中有代码示例，他们对此进行了深入探讨。你是对的。对不起。是的，所以我把这搞砸了。
So Sam is the person who wrote the original article that we'll have both linked. Yeah. And then, yeah, but I have the names mixed up. Protecting the innocent, Jason. It was on purpose. Well, actually, this gentleman who wrote the response to Sam, he also had a really insightful tweet that I happened to stumble upon where he said, you know, regardless of what you think of Godot, the fact that Godot exists is the reason,
所以萨姆是写了我们都会链接的原创文章的那个人。是的。然后，是的，但我把名字搞混了。保护无辜者，杰森。这是故意的。好吧，实际上，这位写了回应萨姆的文章的绅士，他还有一个非常深刻的推文，我偶然碰巧看到了，他说，你知道的，不管你对Godot有什么看法，Godot的存在之所以是原因，
or at least one of the chief reasons, why Unity walked back that pricing plan. So it's sort of like the idea is that open source is ultimately a moat that protects you from the potential of a monopoly or commercial monopoly. Very cool. Yeah, kind of a little bit of foreshadowing here but uh we'll talk about Godot a little bit later on in the show and in our tool of the show but for now we have oh go ahead oh sorry so just make it clear it's yeah so it should have been one one is the benevolent
或者至少是主要原因之一，是因为Unity收回了那个定价计划。所以这就有点像是，开源最终是一条护城河，可以保护你免受垄断或商业垄断的潜在威胁。太酷了。是的，这里有点预告的意思，但我们稍后会在节目中以及我们的节目工具环节中稍微聊聊Godot，但现在我们有——哦，请讲，哦抱歉，所以为了澄清，是的——所以本应是1，1是
dictator for life of Godot so one is the one I was I was talking about responding to Sam so I apologize there for the name mix-ups hopefully uh didn't confuse anyone yeah i told him so now it's time for book of the show what's your book of the show patrick my book of the show you have to listen carefully is math games with bad drawings by ben orlin so uh last duo episode i had math with bad drawings by Orlin. And this is math games. And so this is a pretty interesting read. It takes a lot of games. You probably know about tic-tac-toe, the boxes game where you draw dots everywhere
Godot的终身仁慈独裁者，所以1是我一直在谈论的那个回应萨姆的人，所以我为名字混淆感到抱歉，希望没有把任何人搞糊涂。是的，我告诉过他，所以现在是本期节目图书环节的时间了。帕特里克，你本期推荐的书是什么？我的书是，你得仔细听好了，本·奥林的《画风糟糕的数学游戏》。所以，上期双人节目我推荐了奥林的《画风糟糕的数学》。而这是数学游戏。所以这是一本相当有趣的读物。它涵盖了很多游戏。你可能知道井字棋，还有那种画满点的格子游戏，
and you draw one line at a time and you take turns. It just kind of goes in depth about like, what kind of mathematical areas do these touch on? What are some variations of these games? Like, are the games themselves interesting or not interesting at the start? And then how do you sort of like propel them forward? So in the example of, is it called dots and boxes? I don't remember. Anyways, we have the dots. Yeah, that's right.
你一次画一条线，轮流进行。它只是深入探讨了诸如：这些游戏涉及哪些数学领域？这些游戏的变体有哪些？比如，这些游戏本身在开始时是有趣还是无趣的？然后你如何推动它们前进？所以在“点和方块”这个例子中，它叫这个名字吗？我不记得了。不管怎样，我们有点。是的，没错。
You draw lines and you make a square and then you get to go a bonus turn. And so he goes through some of the strategies, which most people probably stumble upon. But then he gives some other games that sound really similar. And some are sort of a dual, like they're equivalent. And so it's just the same game in a different disguise. But then some are actually sort of fundamentally different. So as an example, you may not think it's a major change, but it actually becomes a fundamentally different problem, which is instead of drawing between two dots up, down, left, right, what happens if you can draw an arbitrary length line up, down, or left, right? How does the game change? And so it feels like this very subtle difference, but in practice, if you can draw, start, and then draw to the right, you know, sort of arbitrary length, the entire dynamics of the
你画线，你做一个正方体，然后你就可以获得额外的一轮。因此，他回顾了一些大多数人可能会偶然发现的策略。但随后他给出了一些听起来非常相似的其他游戏。有些是某种对偶，就像它们是等效的。所以这只是换了件外衣的同一个游戏。但随后有些游戏实际上在根本上是不同的。例如，你可能认为这不是一个重大的改变，但它实际上变成了一个根本不同的问题，那就是：不是在两个点之间向上、向下、向左、向右画线，如果你可以画任意长度的向上、向下或向左、向右的线，会发生什么？游戏将如何改变？因此，这感觉像是一个非常微妙的区别，但在实践中，如果你可以画线、开始然后向右画（你知道的）任意长度，整个游戏的动态就会
game shift around. Wow, really cool. i bought the math with bad drawings um after patrick mentioned it on that episode and it's been very entertaining um you know it has has great it does have great well uh entertaining bad drawings and yeah i've been really entertained i think it's uh it's been it's been good. Definitely not an audio book. Oh, yeah, it wouldn't be a good audio book. Well, yeah, I think I'll grab this one too, probably. Anything with games that I'm kind of a sucker,
发生大转变。哇，真的很酷。帕特里克在那期节目中提到它之后，我买下了《画风糟糕的数学》，它非常有趣，你知道，它有很好的、确实有很好的——呃，有趣的糟糕画作，是的，我真的很开心，我觉得它真的很不错。绝对不是有声书。哦，是的，它不会是一本好的有声书。好吧，是的，我想我也会买一本，可能吧。任何带有游戏的我都无法抗拒，
I have to open the wallet. Amazon's had me figured out. They subsidize this? Yeah, that's right. All right, my book is The Invisible Hook, The Hidden Economics of Pirates. So I always wondered this, like, you know, if you're a pirate, you know, let's say you take over and this is like literally not a software pirate or whatever, but literally a buccaneer pirate, you know, in the 1600s or whatever, you know, if you're a pirate and you take over a ship, like what really happens after that? I mean, could you just sell that ship at a port? I mean, wouldn't they know that you
我得掏钱包了。亚马逊把我都摸透了。他们资助这个吗？是的，没毛病。好的，我的书是《隐形钩：海盗的隐藏经济学》。所以我一直想知道这个，就像，你知道的，如果你是一个海盗，你知道，假设你接管了一艘船，这真的不是一个软件海盗什么的，而是字面意义上的1600年代或某个时期的海盗，你知道，如果你是一个海盗，你接管了一艘船，那之后到底会发生什么？我的意思是，你能在港口直接把那艘船卖掉吗？我的意思是，难道他们不会知道你
stole the ship? I mean, it just, I mean, like imagine in the real world, I guess the equivalent would be like a car thief or something, but, but those those people they have like chop shops that chop the car up i thought you were gonna say nft oh yeah oh my gosh there's there's still people in my social network really pushing nft hard and i'm like dude it's over come on i mean just throw in the towel um but yeah like you know what happens with this giant ship? I mean, you steal this ship. It has like tons and tons of spices in it. You know, like, how do you really get away with that?
偷了这艘船吗？我的意思是，这就像——想象一下在现实世界中，我想这就相当于一个偷车贼什么的，但是，那些人他们有拆车厂来把车拆散。我以为你要说NFT。哦，是的，天哪，我社交网络里仍然有人在大力推NFT，而我就像，老兄，已经结束了，行了吧。我是说，快认输吧。但事实确实如此，你知道，这艘巨轮会发生什么？我的意思是，你偷了这艘船。它里面有成吨成吨的香料。你知道，比如，你怎么能真的逃脱惩罚呢？
How is this profitable? How does that actually work? It's really, really interesting. You know, the way that you can fence an entire ship fence means to, you know, sell something, you know, kind uh that doesn't belong to you um the way you can fence an entire ship or the way that pirates ultimately got spices that they stole and sold them to like you know individual towns and stuff really really interesting stuff one thing i i didn't know about was the extent of these uh they call them letters of marquee so basically
这怎么能盈利？这到底是怎么运作的？真的非常非常有趣。你知道，你如何销赃一整艘船——销赃的意思是（你知道的）出售某些不属于你的东西——你销赃一整艘船的方式，或者海盗最终获得他们偷来的香料并将其出售给（你知道的）各个城镇之类的方式，真的非常非常有趣。有一件事我不知道，那就是这些被称为“私掠许可证”的东西的范围——所以基本上，
the difference between a buccaneer and a pirate is a buccaneer has the authority of at least one country so you know like you might go to the english governor or king or i don't know who but it goes some english authority and he will give you a letter of marquee which basically says you know for example if england's at war with france or spain or what have you you can sink as many or capture as many french boats as you want and the english will in fact they'll reward you for it and so a lot of pirates were actually buccaneers so they would fly like a british flag they would take spanish ships hostage and then they could go to any british or english uh town and sell the ship and sell the stuff right because they have
私掠者和海盗的区别在于，私掠者至少拥有一个国家的授权，所以你知道，你可能会去找英国总督或国王，或者我不知道是谁，但你会去找某个英国官方，他会给你一份私掠许可证，基本上上面写着（你知道的），例如，如果英国与法国或西班牙或诸如此类国家交战，你可以沉没或捕获任意数量的法国船只，事实上英国会为此奖励你。因此，许多海盗实际上都是私掠者，所以他们会悬挂英国国旗，将西班牙船只扣为人质，然后他们可以去任何英国或英格兰城镇出售船只和物品，对吧？因为他们拥有
that authority and so that's how it worked for a lot of people but then you know some of the most notorious pirates they basically had their own you know kind of uh totally unstructured nation so there would be pirate islands where you could you know sell a boat and they would figure out what to do with it of course they'd like charge you um you know premium for that but they would they would figure out a way to make money off that um the whole thing was really interesting i mean i know it's kind of a weird rabbit hole to go down but it i heard i read a lot of things that really surprised me awesome all right that actually sounds really interesting now that you got me now i'm now i'm curious because i feel like it's one of those everyone knows what a pirate is but then if you think like you said one level deeper wait a minute you know hang on what
那种授权，所以这对很多人来说就是这样运作的。但随后（你知道的）一些最臭名昭著的海盗，他们基本上拥有自己的（你知道的某种）完全不受约束的国家，所以会有海盗岛，在那里你可以（你知道的）卖掉一艘船，他们会想办法处理它，当然他们会向你收取（你知道的）高额费用，但他们会想办法从中赚钱。整件事真的很有趣。我的意思是，我知道这有点像是一个奇怪的兔子洞，但我听到、读到了很多真正让我感到惊讶的事情。太棒了。好吧，这听起来真的很酷，现在你把我吸引住了，现在我很好奇，因为我觉得这是那种每个人都知道什么是海盗，但如果你像你所说的那样深入一层去思考：等一下，（你知道的）等等，你
do you actually do with an entire boat that needs a crew like how do you put people on it and sail it to where you want it to go and you need to damage it to to take it over but not damage it so much that like you can't sell it yeah exactly exactly um and uh yeah the whole thing is really is really interesting um another thing that really shocked me was just like how much like physical gold was was was uh transported from south america to europe like it's an unbelievable amount just it had this thing called the treasure fleet it was literally like a huge fleet of giant ships and these were pretty much like no pirate would at least i haven't read of any pirate that would ever challenge this it's just like an enormous juggernaut of a fleet of of like uh you know privateers and all these like boats but they would just transport an unbelievable amount of gold um across the
到底要怎么处理一整艘需要船员的船呢？你如何把人放上去并把它开到你想去的地方？你需要损坏它才能把它夺过来，但又不能损坏得太厉害以至于你无法把它卖掉。是的，没错，没错。而且，整件事真的很、真的很趣。另一件真正让我震惊的事是，从南美洲向欧洲运输了多少实体黄金——这真的是一个难以置信的数量。它有一个叫做“珍宝船队”的东西，它字面意思就像是一个巨大的巨轮船队，这些船基本上没有任何海盗——至少我没有听说过任何海盗会去挑战它——它就像是一个庞大无比的私掠船队和所有这些船只的巨兽，但它们只是在跨大西洋运输
atlantic ocean um so yeah the whole thing is really interesting and yeah it's definitely worth the read oh very good this is time for tool of the show all right what's your tool of the show so mine is a game sticking with uh my classic but this is one i i we don't spend a ton of time on it i think everyone knows what uh this game is or or i we don't spend a ton of time on it i think everyone knows what uh this game is or or if they haven't they're about to lose hours and hours and hours of the life and i apologize in advance um but this game is factorio so factorio i think really almost kicked off a genre i think there was like games that preceded it of course but now there's a lot of follow-on satisfactory dyson sphere program i'm sure there's a dozen others um but
令人难以置信的大量黄金。所以，是的，整件事真的很有趣，而且绝对值得一读。非常好，现在是本期节目工具环节的时间了。好的，你的节目工具是什么？所以我的工具是一个游戏，延续了我的经典，但这是一款我们没有花太多时间讨论的游戏，我想每个人都知道这款游戏是什么，或者——或者我们没有花太多时间讨论它，我想每个人都知道这款游戏是什么，或者如果他们还不知道，他们即将失去生活中数以小时计的时间，我提前道歉，但这款游戏就是《异星工厂》（Factorio）。所以《异星工厂》，我认为它真的几乎开创了一个流派，我想当然有在此之前推出的游戏，但现在有很多后续游戏，比如《幸福工厂》（Satisfactory）、《戴森球计划》（Dyson Sphere Program），我确信还有其他十几种，但
factorio the reason why i recently got into it i wasn't sure i would like it the graphics were follow on satisfactory Dyson sphere program. I'm sure there's a dozen others. But Factorio, the reason why I recently got into it, I wasn't sure I would like it. The graphics were kind of meh. So I played a demo and then I realized I spent more time playing the demo than I probably like have played most video games that I own. And so I realized that I probably should just buy it and play it. But the reason why I started getting into it is they recently did a bunch of
《异星工厂》，我最近开始玩它的原因时，我不确定自己是否会喜欢它。它的图形界面有点平庸。所以我玩了一个演示版，然后我意识到我花在玩演示版上的时间，可能比我拥有的绝大多数电子游戏还要多。所以我意识到我可能应该直接买下来玩。但我开始玩它的原因是，他们最近做了一堆
work to support controllers. I was able to play it on my Steam deck i started getting into it is they uh recently did a bunch of work to support controllers i was able to play it on my steam deck so they have on steam i think they have it on switch now um was is sort of why they added controller support um but this is the reason why i sort of picked it i always knew you need mouse and keyboard and just time with in front of mouse and keyboard after a long day of doing it for work didn't really appeal to me but we talked on the show before i got a steam deck now now. So I've been playing Factorio. I have no idea, to be clear. I know the rabbit hole.
工作来支持控制器。我能够把它在我的Steam Deck上玩，我开始迷上它是因为他们嗯最近做了很多工作来支持控制器，我能够把它在我的Steam Deck上玩，所以他们在Steam上有了，我想他们现在也在Switch上了，嗯，这也就是他们为什么添加控制器支持的原因，但这也是我选择它的原因，我一直知道你需要鼠标和键盘，在做了一整天的工作之后，坐在鼠标和键盘前花时间并不太吸引我，但我们在节目中讨论过，我现在有了一个Steam Deck。所以一直在玩《异星工厂》。为了说清楚，我完全不知道。我知道这个深渊。
I know how people... I don't know what happens in later levels, I'm sure, or later stages. I'm sure your Steam Deck will bog down. But for just picking up and playing, I've played a lot already, and I've never really sort of said, oh man, this is running, this is unbearable.
我知道人们……我不知道在后面的关卡中会发生什么，我确定，或者在后面的阶段。我确信你的Steam Deck会卡顿。但就拿来即玩而言，我已经玩了很多了，而且从来没有觉得，天哪，这运行得太难受了。
This is too slow. Yeah, you know, the thing that Factorio and its descendants have done really well is put you in control of the pace of the game. So if you look at something like civilization, you know, you move your units and then you click and turn and then you have to kind of wait for everybody else and so you know maybe in the beginning of the game when there's a lot or maybe the end of the game in civilization where there's a lot of things going on there's units all over the map then the pace like really slows down um and at the beginning of the game it just feels like the game is taking forever right um you know factorio has this beautiful dynamic where you know as soon as you get the the factories like the beginning factory you're kind of then limited by your own creativity you know you can you can end up with you know even with just the
这太慢了。是的，你知道，《异星工厂》及其后代做得非常好的事情是，让你来掌控游戏的节奏。所以如果你看像《文明》这样的游戏，你知道，你移动单位，然后你点击回合，然后你不得不等待其他所有人，所以你知道，也许在游戏开始时有很多事情，或者在《文明》的游戏结束时有很多事情发生，地图上到处都是单位，然后节奏就真的变慢了，嗯，而在游戏开始时，感觉游戏要进行好久，对吧，嗯，你知道《异星工厂》有这样一个美丽的动态，你知道，一旦你得到了工厂——比如初始工厂，然后你就会被你自己的创造力所限制，你知道，你最终可以，你知道，即使只有
initial factory you can end up with a massive sprawling base or you could have just three factories and you build everything by hand and and so the pace like you your your aptitude is kind of controlling the pace of the game and it never feels like the game kind of gets away from you or is boring yeah we didn't actually say what the game is so i guess for the for the few people who don't know this this is, I guess, a factory simulator. So the rough idea is there are resources out in the world of various types. And then there's ways of, you know, building things to extract resources and then a chain to sort of finished goods. iron ore into iron plates and iron plates into steel beams or into gears or sprockets. And so you sort of have these chains of dependency and you want to build better and better factories that are faster and conveyor belts. But to do that, you need sort of more high tier products, which have levels below them. So eight stages of inputs to get to the item you need to construct your, you know, whatever you're building at the end. And so you build up these longer, longer
最初的工厂，你最终可以拥有一个巨大的庞大基地，或者你也可以只有三个工厂，然后所有的东西都手工建造，因此节奏，你的才能在某种程度上控制着游戏的节奏，它从来不会让你觉得游戏脱离了你的掌控或者很无聊。是的，我们其实没有说这游戏是什么，所以我想对于那些少数不知道的人来说，这大概是一个工厂模拟器。所以大致的想法是，世界上有各种类型的资源。然后有各种方法，你知道，建造东西来提取资源，然后是一条通往成品的链条。铁矿石变成铁板，铁板变成钢梁或者齿轮。所以你会有这些依赖链，并且你想要建造更好、更快的工厂和传送带。但要做到这一点，你需要更高级的产品，它们有更低的级别。所以需要八个阶段的输入来获得你建造最终需要的东西，无论你最后在建造什么。所以你建立起这些越来越长的
chains, like Jason said, I guess a lot of analogy for code, you can, you have to debug it when something's going into the wrong, wrong input, you got to like, you can have spaghetti code, you can have a very modularized and everyone sort of takes their own, own bent to it. And it sounds horrible. I know it really does. But it's just one of those things to like Jason said, kind of zone out and you just monkey around. And there's no real exact winning and losing.
链条，就像杰森说的，我想这有很多代码的类比，你可以，当某些东西进入错误的输入时，你必须调试它，你可能会有面条式代码，你可以有一个非常模块化的代码，每个人都会有自己的偏好。这听起来很糟糕。我知道确实如此。但就像杰森说的，这只是那种可以放空自我、随便捣鼓的事情之一。而且没有真正确切的输赢。
You're just trying to get better and better. Yep. Yeah, it's really satisfying. Cool. All right. My tool of the show is AI Hero, which is a game that I made. I've been working on this game for years and years, just a tiny bit of time here and there. And basically, I set a goal for myself many years ago that I wanted to teach AI, but I wanted to teach in a way that had no words. And I felt like that was a succinct way of kind of explaining
你只是在努力变得越来越好。是的。是的，这真的很令人满足。酷。好的。我本期节目的工具是AI Hero，这是我制作的一款游戏。我开发这款游戏很多年了，断断续续地花了一点点时间。基本上，我多年前给自己设定了一个目标，我想教人工智能，但我想用一种没有文字的方式来教。我觉得这是一种概括性的解释方式
you know you know that i wanted to to teach to demonstrate ai but without having to tell people like you know turn to page 569 of this conference proceedings right so um it's pretty ambitious goal and it took me a really long time to kind of find the fun so to speak so um the premise of the of the game and you can get it on ios and android it's totally free there's no ads there's no in-app purchases or none of that stuff um yeah the premise of it is you have to set these control points in a way that creates certain curves or certain circles or other shapes. And those shapes have to kind of separate clusters of labels. So you're on this graph grid, and there's sort of a cluster of green points and a cluster of red points. And you have to,
你知道，你知道我想去教，去演示人工智能，但又不必告诉人们，比如，你知道，翻到这个会议录的第569页，所以，嗯，这是一个相当雄心勃勃的目标，我花了很长时间才找到所谓的乐趣，所以，嗯，这个游戏的前提，你可以在iOS和Android上获取，它完全免费，没有广告，没有应用内购买，没有那些乱七八糟的东西，嗯，它的前提是你必须以某种方式设置这些控制点，从而产生某些曲线或某些圆形或其他形状。这些形状必须能够分离标签的集群。所以你在这个图表网格上，有一簇绿色的点和一簇红色的点。你必须，
by using your finger and moving these control points, you know, find that curve that separates those points. And then as it gets harder, you end up with four, five, six, seven different categories. And so you have to have these sort of intersecting shapes that can allow you to separate all these different classes. So it turns out, you know, with maybe two shapes, you can actually separate, you know, four or five, six different classes if you like bend one shape around another and stuff. So, you know, it did kind of accomplish that thing I set out to do. You know, originally the plan was for it to be an educational game. What I found is it really appealed to people of all ages. You know, my kids played it, thought it was pretty fun, but a lot of adults were finding it fun. And so I just ended up releasing it as kind of an AI themed puzzle game for all ages. But it's written in Godot, so kind of a throwback to 10-15 minutes ago. I don't have to worry about Unity coming after me for my free game or anything like that.
通过使用你的手指移动这些控制点，你知道，找到能够分离这些点的曲线。随着难度增加，你最终会有四、五、六、七个不同的类别。所以你必须拥有这些相互交叉的形状，使你能够分离所有这些不同的类别。结果证明，你知道，可能用两个形状，你实际上可以分离，你知道，四、五、六个不同的类别，如果你把一个形状绕着另一个形状弯曲之类的。所以，你知道，它确实实现了我最初设定的目标。你知道，最初的计划是把它做成一个教育游戏。我发现它真的吸引了所有年龄段的人。你知道，我的孩子们玩过它，觉得挺好玩的，但很多成年人也觉得它很好玩。所以我最终只是把它作为一个人人适用的、以人工智能为主题的益智游戏发布了。它是用Godot编写的，所以有点像对10-15分钟前的呼应。我不用担心Unity会因为我的免费游戏而找我麻烦之类的。
But I did find Godot to be very pleasant to work with. It is a 2D game, so it's not a huge technical achievement. And so I wouldn't say I stressed Godot in any big way. But I found the feedback loop to be really nice. One of the things that Unity and Godot do which i think is really interesting is they let you basically play you know like a module of the game like for example um in godot they're called scenes i don't know what they're called in unity but you know like you could have a scene which is uh mario right and you could have another scene which is you know level three or something and you can actually just play the mario scene just by itself as a game and you could just be mario and just jump around in an empty world um and so that way you can test like
但我确实发现使用Godot非常愉快。它是一个2D游戏，所以不是什么巨大的技术成就。因此我不会说我在任何重大方面给Godot施加了压力。但我发现反馈循环真的很好。Unity和Godot所做的事情之一，我认为非常有趣，就是它们基本上让你玩，你知道，比如游戏的一个模块，例如，嗯，在Godot中它们被称为场景，我不知道它们在Unity中叫什么，但你知道，比如你可以有一个场景是马里奥，对吧，你可以有另一个场景是第三关什么的，你实际上可以仅仅把马里奥场景作为一个游戏来玩，你就可以成为马里奥在一个空旷的世界里跳来跳去，这样你就可以测试
certain pieces of the game without having to test the whole thing. I found that really useful as I was developing. But yeah, check it out. It's totally free. Hopefully you'll find it pretty fun. Awesome. Alright, I think it's time to talk about desktop user interfaces. Yeah, so Patrick, what is a user interface? It is an interface a user uses.
游戏的某些部分，而不必测试整个部分。我在开发时发现这非常有用。但是，去看看吧。它是完全免费的。希望你会觉得它挺好玩的。太棒了。好的，我想是时候讨论桌面用户界面了。是的，帕特里克，什么是用户界面？它就是用户使用的界面。
All right. That's the end of the show. Everyone, Patreon, subscribe. No, I mean, I think this is something everyone bumps into or starts out into, which is, you know, have some cool functions, some application. Jason was just talking about his game. But ultimately, we need a way of displaying that to the the user so of course uh you know currently a lot of that could be web you could build a website with you know javascript or another another language that that gives you that ability um it could be a command line interface it could be hey i'm prompting the user and in sort of a text adventure game could be a user interface there but i still want to have options displaying inventory and stuff but the one i think we're going to talk
好的。节目到此结束。大家，Patreon，订阅。不，我的意思是，我认为这是每个人都会遇到或开始接触的事情，也就是，你知道，有一些很酷的功能，某个应用程序。杰森刚才在谈论他的游戏。但归根结底，我们需要一种向用户展示它的方法，所以当然，嗯，目前很多都可以是网络端，你可以用JavaScript或其他语言构建一个网站，这赋予了你这种能力，它可以是命令行界面，可以是，嘿，我在提示用户，在某种文字冒险游戏中可以是那里的用户界面，但我仍然想要有显示库存等选项，但我认为我们要讨论的
about today is when you're on a you know desktop so windows or mac os or linux or dot dot dot dot i'm not going to try to list them all because someone's going to write us in that we left theirs off and you want to you want to have a way for a user to interact with a running program uh and you need to write code to do that yeah that's right and so um you know i don't know if we've ever done an episode on command line interfaces maybe that needs to be the next episode but um you know there's there's a lot uh around you know making a good command line interface and you know terminal uh you can there's a whole bunch of really interesting programs there. But by and large, when most people think of a user interface for the desktop, they're thinking about something
今天的主题是当你使用桌面端时，比如Windows、macOS或Linux，或者点点点点，我不会试图把它们全部列出来，因为有人会写信告诉我们我们漏掉了他们的，而你想为用户提供一种与正在运行的程序进行交互的方式，你需要为此编写代码。是的，没错，所以，嗯，你知道，我不知道我们是否做过关于命令行界面的节目，也许那需要成为下一期节目，但，嗯，你知道，有很多关于制作一个好的命令行界面和终端的内容，你可以在那里找到一大堆非常有趣程序。但总的来说，当大多数人想到桌面用户界面时，他们想到的是某种
that opens some kind of window and has a point and click interface and all of that. It's worth calling out that this is a lot more complicated than web and mobile. I mean, mobile, the UI is really front and center to the whole experience. A lot of mobile apps are just veneer around business logic that runs somewhere else. Like imagine your banking app, for example. When you go to pay somebody in your banking app or pay a bill, your phone doesn't literally pay the bill. Your phone just sends a request to some server that does all of that.
会打开某种窗口并具有点按界面的东西，诸如此类。值得指出的是，这比网页端和移动端要复杂得多。我的意思是，在移动端，用户界面确实是整个体验的重中之重。许多移动应用程序只是在其他地方运行的业务逻辑外面的一层外表。比如想象一下你的银行应用程序，例如。当你去在你的银行应用程序中向某人付款或支付账单时，你的手机并不是真的在支付账单。你的手机只是向处理所有这些事情的某个服务器发送请求。
Similarly, on the website, your browser isn't literally calling some API to move money around. All of those are going to the server. So using, let's say, Chase Bank, for example. So your browser goes to the chase server and the chase server does server to server communication so all the business logic lives there um conversely the desktop is sort of the opposite where if you want to do business logic if you
同样地，在网站上，你的浏览器并不是真的在调用某个API来转移资金。所有这些都是发往服务器的。所以使用，比方说大通银行（Chase Bank），例如。所以你的浏览器访问大通银行的服务器，然后大通银行的服务器进行服务器到服务器的通信，因此所有的业务逻辑都驻留在那里，相反，桌面端则有点相反，如果你想做业务逻辑，如果你
need a good debugger if um you want to build a analysis tool and things like that. It's great, but for graphical user interfaces, the desktop is challenging. And often it could be hard to know even where to get started there. I feel like... Yeah, go ahead. A few years ago, I think the story was much more around per operating system building it know, building it.
需要一个好的调试器，如果嗯你想构建一个分析工具之类的话。这很棒，但对于图形用户界面来说，桌面端具有挑战性。而且通常甚至很难知道从哪里开始。我觉得……是的，请继续。几年前，我觉得故事更多的是围绕着每个操作系统来构建它，你知道，去构建它。
So you would, you know, if you're building a Windows, you would go into Visual Studio and you would, you know, kind of do the very Windows specific way. If you're doing Linux, maybe you would do something, something else. And everybody sort of had their own sort of way of developing this, you know, so-called native, native looking apps. And I think as you were kind of mentioning, I think that's where the phones have an expected feel. Like how things work on Android is actually different than how things are expected to work on iOS. So if you have an iOS app, people expect certain functionalities and behaviors
所以你会，你知道，如果你在构建一个Windows应用，你会进入Visual Studio，然后你会，你知道，用非常Windows特定方式来做。如果你在做Linux，也许你会做别的。每个人都有自己开发这种所谓原生、原生外观应用程序的方式。我想正如你刚才提到的，这就是为什么手机有一种预期的感觉。在Android上的工作方式实际上与iOS上预期的工作方式不同。所以如果你有一个iOS应用，人们期望围绕滑动或上下拖拽等某些功能和行为，
around like swipes or around dragging up or down or like certain things that's like very pre-canned. Whereas I feel there was more differences historically between like how something would work in linux versus windows versus mac os how buttons would look and how interactions would be set but there's also more diversity just within a platform so like you mentioned in windows or whatever like or or whatever there there could be you know a ui popping up that has i guess what you would call like a normal desktop app but to be clear you could also pop open a game and have a ui and a window as well and have a HUD and, you know,
这些都是非常现成的。然而我觉得，历史上Linux和Windows与macOS在某些东西的工作方式上，按钮的外观和交互的设置方式上，存在更多差异。但仅仅在一个平台内部也有更多样性，就像你在Windows或其他什么中提到的，或者无论什么，可能会弹出一个用户界面，它具有我想你称之为普通桌面应用的东西，但要明确的是，你也可以弹出一个游戏并在窗口中拥有一个用户界面和一个HUD，并且，你知道，
have like buttons that are graphical and they look very different. And so there's all these, you know, different ones. But I think today, a number of like platforms have come to also allow people to develop across multiple, you know, sort of targeted desktop OS environments and sort of really capture this. They really sort of come into os environments and sort of really capture this they really sort of come into their own around hey this is like a good way of doing this development strategy yeah that makes a ton of sense another thing too is you know in the case of mobile um in the case of web the web is extremely uniform people have done an amazing job of of setting up things
拥有图形化的按钮，而且它们看起来非常不同。所以有所有这些不同的东西。但我认为今天，许多平台也开始允许人们跨多个，你知道，某种目标的桌面操作系统环境进行开发，并真正捕捉到这一点。它们真正开始在操作系统环境中崭露头角，并真正捕捉到这一点，它们真正开始独树一帜，围绕着，嘿，这是一种很好的开发策略。是的，这非常合理。另一件事也是，你知道，在移动端的情况下，在网页端的情况下，网页端极其统一，人们在建立
so that you can have relatively common experience. It doesn't matter whether you're on the phone or the desktop. And there's all sorts of ways to do these reactive websites where if the column width is shorter, then it doesn't do a sidebar. And all of that is really easy to do. I mean, even programmingthrowdown.com, if you look at it at a phone or if you shrink the browser window on your desktop
相对共同的体验方面做得非常出色。无论你是在手机上还是在桌面上，这都不重要。而且有各种各样的方法来制作这些响应式网站，如果列宽较短，那么它就不会做侧边栏。所有这些都真的很容易做到。我的意思是，即使是编程播客网站（programmingthrowdown.com），如果你在手机上查看它，或者如果你在桌面上将浏览器窗口缩小得
to be really thin, you know, things will start collapsing and things that were just always visible become little hamburger menus. And I didn't code any of that myself. I mean, all of that is just built into the web tools that I was using. On mobile, you know, there's really only two big players, right?
非常窄，你知道，内容就会开始折叠，那些原本总是可见的东西变成小汉堡菜单。我并没有自己编写任何这些代码。我的意思是，所有这些都内置在我使用的网页工具中。在移动端，你知道，真的只有两个大玩家，对吧？
There's iOS and Android. And because mobile is so important, most companies or even most developers will create two copies of their code. So you'll have an iOS app app you'll have an android app and they'll you know you can use flutter and some of these things but most people i would say the vast majority are right are building two separate apps and you never have to worry then about like oh like what if i need to do something that is you know not supported by flutter or i need to use this ios plugin and interop and all of that um conversely on desktop you know i don't know what the market share numbers are like but i always feel like i need to support at least mac and windows um but um if not if not also linux but um i'm usually in much more of a hurry when i'm building
有iOS和Android。因为移动端非常重要，大多数公司甚至大多数开发者都会创建两份代码副本。所以你会有一个iOS应用，你会有个Android应用，他们会，你知道，你可以使用Flutter和其中一些东西，但我会说绝大多数人都在构建两个独立的应用程序，这样你就不必担心，哦，比如如果我需要做一些不被Flutter支持的事情，或者我需要使用这个iOS插件和互操作性以及所有这些。相反，在桌面上，你知道，我不知道市场份额的数据是多少，但我总觉得我需要至少支持Mac和Windows，但，如果不是，如果不是也支持Linux，但，我在构建时通常更加匆忙
a desktop app right because usually it's an app for developers. It's an internal tool or it's something like that. And so I don't want to have three different versions. Like I don't want to spend that time. And so you're kind of caught with the situation where you have to be really quick, but you're using a, you know, you're in a place that isn't very well-traveled, so it's a difficult position to be in. So I have a few different options here.
一个桌面应用程序，对吧，因为通常它是给开发者用的应用。它是一个内部工具或类似的东西。所以我不想有三个不同的版本。我不想花那个时间。所以你陷入了一种情况，你必须非常快，但你处在一个并不是很多人走过的领域，所以这是一个困难的处境。所以我这里有几个不同的选项。
I'll kind of list them in no particular order. I've actually really enjoyed Qt. Have you ever used Qt, Patrick, as a developer? Only a little bit. I think Qt does one of those, like predating a lot of the sort of modern, more portable coding practices. So in C++, I feel like, you know, Qt was a big influence there. So we have like Qt and Boost, but then the standard library coming along and getting a lot better. But they had to introduce a lot of the more high-level modules really early to make UI programming work.
我会按随机顺序列出它们。我其实真的很喜欢Qt。帕特里克，你作为开发者用过Qt吗？只用了一点点。我认为Qt是其中之一，它早于许多现代的、更便携的编码实践。所以在C++中，我觉得，你知道，Qt在那里有很大的影响力。所以我们有Qt和Boost，但随后标准库出现并变得好得多。为了让UI编程工作，他们不得不很早就引入了许多更高级别的模块。
And so I feel like, yeah, I did interact with it and sort of, we'll talk about later, but like asynchronous or, you know, threading and these kinds of things, which had very poor sort of out-of-the-box support. And then Qt sort of stepped up and did that. So not only has it got the UI stuff, but it has a lot of C++ modules that, you know, came along later in other forms, but they were pretty early to the game
所以我感觉，是的，我确实与它进行了交互，并且有点像，我们稍后会讨论的，比如异步或，你知道，线程以及这些类型的东西，它们开箱即用的支持非常糟糕。然后Qt挺身而出做到了这一点。所以它不仅拥有UI东西，而且它有很多C++模块，这些模块后来以其他形式出现，但它们在游戏中算是很早的
in helping like level up the sophistication of C++ developers. Oh, very cool. Yeah, I've actually only used PyQt or I think now it's called Qt for Python, which is like a, you know, a wrapper around the C++ code. And so I could definitely see the C++ influence when I look at Qt for Python,
帮助提升C++开发者复杂度的水平。哦，太酷了。是的，其实我只用过PyQt，或者我想现在它叫Qt for Python，它就像是一个，你知道，围绕C++代码的包装器。所以当我看着Qt for Python时，我绝对能看出C++的影响，
just the way that objects are kind of passed into other objects. It doesn't feel really that Pythonic. But the things that really stood out, so Qt, the idea with qt is that you know it's not a native looking app so if you were to build an app in qt on your windows machine and you were to build an app using the visual studio um you know a designer they're gonna look totally different so qt has their own kind of buttons, their own text boxes that they have designed themselves. And so, you know, at some point, like way down in the Qt code, like
对象传递给其他对象的方式。感觉并不是很 Pythonic。但真正突出的地方在于 Qt，Qt 的理念是它不是一个原生外观的应用，所以如果你在 Windows 机器上使用 Qt 构建一个应用，然后再用 Visual Studio 的设计器构建一个应用，它们的视觉效果会完全不同。所以 Qt 有自己的按钮和文本框，都是他们自己设计的。因此，你知道，在 Qt 代码的底层深处，比如说
they're rendering like raw pixels. So they've like, you know, they have total control over the canvas and the window, you know, you're obviously abstracted from all of that. But you know, it has this nice, like side effect where, you know, if you have a qt app on mac or on windows or on linux you know it should look more or less the same i couldn't say it would be exactly pixel for pixel but but you know it's the it's it's going to be very consistent um conversely if you were to use wx widgets which which is another option, that's a very interesting tool. The way it works is you write your WX widgets code and then it kind of on the fly, I guess it's like a transpiler, although it's not really compiling, but like on the fly,
它们是在渲染原始像素。所以它们对画布和窗口拥有完全的控制权，当然你被抽象屏蔽掉了所有这些细节。但它有一个很好的副作用，如果你在 Mac、Windows 或 Linux 上运行 Qt 应用，它们的外观大体上应该是相同的。我不能说完全做到像素级的一致，但你知道的，它将会非常一致。相反，如果你使用 wxWidgets，这也是另一个选择，这是一个非常有趣的工具。它的工作原理是，你编写 wxWidgets 代码，然后它会实时地——我猜它有点像转译器（transpiler），虽然它并不是真的在编译，但就像是实时地
it's mapping your function calls to the low-level thing. So for example, you tell WXWidgets, draw a text box. And if it has some check, it says, oh, am I on Windows? Oh, I am. OK, call this native Windows function to draw a text box. Oh, I'm on Linux. OK, call this native Linux function.
将你的函数调用映射到底层的东西。例如，你告诉 wxWidgets：绘制一个文本框。如果有某种检查，它会说：“哦，我在 Windows 上吗？是的。好的，调用这个原生的 Windows 函数来绘制文本框。哦，我在 Linux 上。好的，调用这个原生的 Linux 函数。”
And so you get a native UI. At the time, this was like WX widgets is very, very dated, or it's not data is very modern, kept up to date, but it's started a long time ago. You know, and at the time, you know, people were much more in tune with what a desktop app should look like on Windows. And so WX widgets, you know, targeting, you know, resolving down to these native desktop widgets, you know, was kind of a nice look and feel. It has the downside that, you know, if, for example, a text box is taller in Linux than it is in Windows, well, then it's going to look taller. And so if you run the same app, and you expected the text box to be, you know, 60 pixels high, and now Linux, it's 70 pixels high now, now, like maybe part of your app, you know, fell off the bottom of the page, and you can't get to it. And there's just a bunch of visual inconsistencies like this. So you really have to, you know, run your app and all these different OSs all the time and make sure that it looks good in all of them. So that's kind of the trade off
这样你就能得到一个原生的 UI。当时，wxWidgets 已经非常、非常陈旧了——或者说它不是陈旧，它其实很现代化，一直保持更新，但它诞生于很久以前。那时候，人们对桌面应用在 Windows 上应该是什么样子有更多的共识。所以 wxWidgets 针对并还原到这些原生的桌面组件，呈现出一种很棒的外观和感觉。它的缺点是，如果例如 Linux 中的文本框比 Windows 中的高，那么它看起来就会更高。因此，如果你运行同一个应用，而你期望文本框是 60 像素高，但在 Linux 中变成了 70 像素高，那么你的应用底部的一部分可能就会被截断，你无法访问它。诸如此类的一致性视觉问题会有一大堆。所以你必须不断在所有这些不同的操作系统上运行你的应用，并确保它们在每个系统上看起来都很棒。这就是其中的权衡。
there. I feel like Qt is probably a better bet now. I mean, people, Qt has taken like such a large market share that people kind of have a spot in their brain for the qt ui you know so i don't think you're shocking people anymore and you know you have the you don't have the other downsides you brought up an interesting point there if you go back i don't know exactly when wx widgets i guess we're looking up but if you go back 10 15 years ago 15 years ago people probably i mean that's some folks listening are like uh what no i'm not going back there i don't remember what's going on uh but when i was a newborn when you go back 15 years though like most folks didn't know how to use a if they said i know how to use a computer they meant like
我觉得现在 Qt 可能是更好的选择。我的意思是，Qt 已经占据了如此巨大的市场份额，以至于人们在脑海中对 Qt 的 UI 已经有了一个概念，所以你不会再震惊到大家了。而且你也没有带来其他缺点。你刚才提出了一个很有趣的观点，如果回溯过去——我不知道 wxWidgets 是什么时候诞生的，我想我们可以查一下——如果你回溯 10 到 15 年前，15 年前人们可能——有些在听节目的朋友可能会想：“啊？什么？我才不回过去呢，我不记得当时发生了什么。”但当我还是个新生儿的时候，如果你回溯到 15 年前，大多数人根本不知道怎么使用一个——如果他们说“我知道怎么用电脑”，他们的意思是
i know how to use windows and i know how to use like these apps in windows uh they probably didn't really bump into other operating systems or if they were on, you know, OSX at the time, I guess, like, you know, they knew or Linux, they knew one thing. But now in our guests and a little bit in our modern lives, I think it's much more common for people like most of the folks I know and work with, you know, they'll have a phone that runs some operating system, Android or iOS, they probably have an operating system with apps on their TV that's different. They have one on, you know, their desktop is something, but they might have a gaming desktop and a laptop for work and their laptop may be a MacBook, but their
“我知道怎么用 Windows，我知道怎么用 Windows 里的这些应用”。他们可能真的没接触过其他操作系统，或者如果他们当时使用的是 OSX 或 Linux，他们只了解其中一种。但现在，在我们的嘉宾以及我们现代生活中，我觉得这种情况要常见得多。我认识和合作的大多数人，他们拥有的手机运行着某种操作系统（Android 或 iOS），他们的电视上可能也有带应用的操作系统，而且是不同的系统。他们的桌面是某种系统，但他们可能既有一台用于游戏的桌面电脑，又有一台用于工作的笔记本电脑，笔记本电脑可能是 MacBook，而
desktop is a Windows gaming machine. So I feel like people are much more likely to have encountered and be proficient at various operating systems. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. And on the, you know, coming at it from the other direction, operating systems have largely standardized on an ideal user interface. And you can read all about material UI and all these different kind of philosophies around UI. And I think a lot of that has collapsed to where, you know, you have a pretty good expectation when you do something on your TV, what it's going to do. Like most people know, you know, if you press on a text box on your TV or your phone or whatever, a keyboard is going to pop up. Right.
桌面电脑则是 Windows 游戏机。所以我觉得人们更有可能接触并精通各种操作系统。是的，这非常合理。从另一个方向来看，操作系统在很大程度上已经朝着理想的用户界面标准化了。你可以去了解 Material UI 以及所有关于 UI 的不同设计理念。我认为很多东西最后都收敛了，你在电视上做某个操作时，你对它会有相当准确的预期，知道它会做什么。就像大多数人知道的那样，如果你在电视或手机等设备的文本框上按下，就会弹出一个键盘。对吧。
So these are just assumptions that you couldn't make. Here's a random piece of trivia,rick how old is wx widgets take a guess oh it's pretty i i i mean i know i i feel pretty good about saying it's at least when i started working which i'm gonna say how many but i i greater than 15 so i'm gonna guess 20 it is 31 years old no way that is wild um way older i thought um so yeah qt and wx widgets they occupy the same space more or less uh one thing that's really important that i highly recommend is um there's something called qt creator and in wx widgets it's called wx form designer and there's probably a new one now that's that's that's a program that i used a long time ago but these things will do code generation so you know
所以这些都是你以前无法做出的假设。这里有一个随机的冷知识，里克，猜猜 wxWidgets 有多老？猜一个。哦，它的历史挺——我的意思是，我知道，我觉得至少可以说它在我开始工作时就有了。我要说多少年呢？但我猜它大于 15 年，所以我猜 20 年。它已经 31 岁了！不会吧，太疯狂了。比我想象的要老得多。所以，Qt 和 wxWidgets 大致占据相同的空间。有一件非常重要且我强烈推荐的事情是，有一个叫作 Qt Creator 的工具，而在 wxWidgets 中它叫作 wxform designer（wx 表单设计器），现在可能有一个更新的版本了，那是很久以前我用过的程序。这些工具可以进行代码生成，所以
you kind of set up the the layout the way you want you say oh i want text box here i want a label here you know reserve this spot for some custom widget which you don't know about but i'm telling you it's a certain size but a combo box here and then uh and then you press a button and it generates code it can generate c++ code it can generate python code and so that python code that it generates you can actually run that and you will get a form or you know a total desktop app it's just none of the buttons will do anything right um and all of the spin boxes will go to infinity there's no guardrails on them right um and so then you know you have to go and implement all that business logic but um but yeah that those tools are incredibly powerful like you could end up spending a lot of time just kind of aligning things you
你可以按自己想要的方式设置布局，比如：我想要一个文本框在这里，我想要一个标签在这里，为某个你目前还不了解的自定义控件预留这个位置（但我告诉你它是一个特定大小），这里放一个组合框（combo box）。然后你按下一个按钮，它就会生成代码。它可以生成 C++ 代码，也可以生成 Python 代码。所以它生成的 Python 代码，你实际上是可以直接运行的，你会得到一个表单，或者说一个完整的桌面应用——只不过所有的按钮都点不动，对吧？
know doing a whole bunch of visual work and if you're sitting there looking at code saying like okay line 67 you know this object needs to be like a little bit further down it's kind of hard sort of like a uh what is it rubbing your belly and patting your head at the same time or whatever it was like it's kind of hard to like write code but then be thinking solely about how this is going to look it's much much easier to use a graphical designer um and it has this another this other nice side effect where it kind of keeps your ui and your business logic separate because if you put business logic in those files and you rerun the designer well guess what it just deleted all of your
所有的微调框（spin boxes）都会无限延伸，上面没有任何安全防护网，对吧？然后你必须自己去实现所有的业务逻辑。但是，这些工具确实极其强大。你可能最终会花大量时间去对齐元素，
business logic so it kind of forces you to like separate those two things, which is you might look at that and say, that's really frustrating, but you'll be better off for it. I think the next one that we're going to talk about is sort of, I guess it was surprising. Like when I first heard about it, I sort of laughed and was like, what? No, it's not going to be a good idea.
做一大堆视觉方面的工作。如果你坐在代码前看着屏幕说：“好吧，第 67 行，这个对象需要再往下移一点”，这其实挺难的。这有点像……嗯，叫什么来着？就像左手画圆右手画方一样，或者类似的事情。一边写代码，一边还要纯粹思考这东西最终会是什么外观，这真的很难。使用图形化设计器要简单得多。
And it still does get ridicule from the sort of like optimization people. Like, oh, this is such an inefficient way of doing things. It's so slow. And that was when Chrome released, one of the things they did separate from just the browser
它还有另一个很好的副作用，那就是它能将你的 UI 和业务逻辑分离开来。因为如果你把业务逻辑写在那些文件中，然后重新运行设计器，猜怎么着？它会直接删掉你所有的
is they released a sort of high efficiency C++ JavaScript execution engine so that you could run JavaScript sort of on your desktop and use it for things outside of Chrome if you wanted. I think it's V8, I think is what it was called. And so this combination and having an open source component to the Chromium, but also to this V8 engine enabled this next one, which is Electron, which really sort of was the first time I at least encountered people truly going for this hybrid thing on desktop where like you're writing almost a web page, but it's also a desktop app.
业务逻辑。所以它在某种程度上强制你将这两者分离开来。你可能会觉得这很令人沮丧，但这样做对你更有好处。我想我们要谈的下一个话题是，某种程度上——我猜它挺让人意外的。当我第一次听说它的时候，我笑了笑，心想：“什么？不，这绝对不是个好主意。”
Yeah. And so, you know, if you use Visual Studio Code or if you use Discord, the desktop app, these are either done in Electron or they're done in a derivative. So I think nowadays there's Neutrino. There's a whole bunch of alternatives. But without any loss of generality, we're going to talk about the first one, which is Electron. But a ton of really popular apps are actually written in Electron. So the way Electron works, basically,
而且它现在仍然会受到那些所谓“优化派”人士的嘲笑，比如：“天哪，这是一种多么低效的做事方式，太慢了。”那就是当 Chrome 发布的时候，除了浏览器本身之外，他们做的一件事
if you've ever built a website, you've probably started by testing the website out on your own computer. So you spin up a very simple web server on your own computer, and you go to localhost colon 8088,
是发布了一个高效率的 C++ JavaScript 执行引擎，这样如果你愿意的话，你可以在桌面上运行 JavaScript，并将其用于 Chrome 之外的事情。我想它叫 V8，如果我没记错的话。所以这种组合，加上 Chromium 的开源组件以及这个 V8 引擎，促成了下一个技术的诞生——Electron。这可以说是至少我第一次遇到人们真正在桌面上尝试这种混合架构：你写的东西几乎是一个网页，但它同时也是一个桌面应用。
something like that, and you get to see your website, and you can interact with it, and make changes, and reload, and all that. And you get to see your website and you can interact with it and make changes and reload and all of that. And then when you're happy, you deploy it to some server that other people can look at. And so the idea with Electron is, you know, you just, you just live in that first part, right? So when an Electron app starts, you know, it starts a local web server that, you know, only your local machine can get to
是的。所以，如果你使用 Visual Studio Code，或者使用 Discord 的桌面应用，这些要么是用 Electron 构建的，要么是用它的衍生版本构建的。我想现在还有 Neutrino，以及一大堆其他的替代方案。但为了具代表性起见，我们只讨论第一个，也就是 Electron。不过，有大量非常流行的应用实际上都是用 Electron 编写的。Electron 的工作原理基本上是：
it's locked down. And then separately, you have a program that visits that web server. And so in the case of, let's say, Visual Studio Code, you know, it starts up a web server, and then it has its own internal browser. This is getting to Patrick's comment. You're deploying a literal browser with every app. And so it launches its own browser, which knows to talk to its own uh web server and so you get this desktop app um but you have all of the advantages of the web frameworks so you know we talked about how you know the website knows what size it is and people have written zillions of lines of code to make it look beautiful like in all these different situations and you get all of that in a desktop app.
如果你曾经构建过网站，你可能最开始都是在自己的电脑上测试网站。所以在你自己的电脑上启动一个非常简单的网页服务器，然后访问 localhost 冒号 8088，
So Electron is extremely powerful. For example, if you need something that draws a bunch of graphs, well, Qt has some basic graphing structure if you want to plot some time series and things like that. But if you start getting into complicated graphs, if you need certain scatter plots, if you need some kind of clustering,
诸如此类的地址，你就能看到你的网站，与它交互，进行修改、重新加载，诸如此类。当你满意之后，再把它部署到其他人可以访问的服务器上。所以 Electron 的核心理念就是，你只需要一直停留在第一阶段，对吧？因此，当 Electron 应用启动时，它会启动一个本地网页服务器，这个服务器
you need to visualize that. The web just has so many resources, such a long tail of different resources that you can be confident you'll find just about anything. And so you don't have to worry about that. You can bring it in. It has this other benefit where if you do want, I mean, Discord's a good example of this. If you want to have a website and a desktop app,
只有你本地的机器才能访问，它是被锁定保护的。然后另外，你会运行一个程序去访问这个网页服务器。以 Visual Studio Code 为例，它启动一个网页服务器，然后拥有它自己的内部浏览器。这就呼应了帕特里克的评论：你实际上是在每个应用里都部署了一个真正的浏览器。所以它会启动自己的浏览器，该浏览器知道如何与它自己的网页服务器进行通信。这样你就得到了一个桌面应用，但同时又拥有了所有 Web 框架的优势——我们之前谈到过，比如网站知道它自己的尺寸，并且人们已经编写了海量的代码来让它在各种不同的情况下都能呈现得无比精美，你可以在桌面应用中获得这一切。
well, now you only have to write it once. The same UI code that if you go to discord.com is literally the same UI code you're running in the desktop app and so that uh saves them a lot of work not being a web developer it's still it's kind of like confusing to me like it boggles my mind that it like sort of works and it does like you said i use i used atom for a long time i think it's now like deprecated in favor of vs code um but it's just kind of weird to me that it just works like you are like you said you're running a like custom browser but you don't know it just feels normal it just feels like a regular app yeah i mean you have this other issue which is um most of these like Electron, Neutrino, they're running a JavaScript web server. So even the
因此 Electron 非常强大。例如，如果你需要绘制一堆图表，Qt 确实提供了一些基础的图表结构，如果你想绘制时间序列之类的数据。但如果你开始涉及复杂的图表，如果你需要某些散点图，或者需要某种聚类，
server is JavaScript. And so that means is if your business logic is in C++, now you actually need a third process, you know, you need the browser, you need the web server that's hosting the UI. And now you need your business logic in a third program and you have to do inter-process communication to pass you know so so for example in discord right you click a button let's say now discord might all be written in javascript but let's pretend like let's pretend like the business logic is written in c++ just to explain so you know in discord you click a button so that's you know the browser makes a http post to the web server saying you know patrick click the join channel button and then that thing you know makes an inter-process communication call to the c++ code to say hey patrick you know click the
你需要将其实现可视化，网络上拥有如此之多的资源，拥有各种各样长尾的资源，以至于你可以确信几乎能找到任何东西。所以你无需为此担心，可以直接拿来使用。它还有另一个好处，如果你确实希望——Discord 就是一个很好的例子——如果你既想要一个网站又想要一个桌面应用，
join channel game that c++ code probably makes another HTTP request to some Discord server where it actually happens. And so you have a lot of these hops. Don't let that scare you, though. I mean, that sounds scary. It's like, oh, I have to set up this code contract, this three-layer code contract to do anything. But in exchange, what you get is really powerful.
那么现在你只需要编写一次代码。如果你访问 discord.com，所看到的 UI 代码和你在桌面应用中运行的 UI 代码完全是同一套。这为他们省去了大量的工作。作为一个非 Web 开发人员，这对我来说仍然有点令人困惑，它让我感到匪夷所思，它竟然真的能运作，而且正如你所说，我曾经使用 Atom 很久，我想它现在为了 VS Code 已经被弃用了……但它竟然能直接运行，这让我觉得有点奇怪。就像你说的，你运行的是一个定制浏览器，但你根本感觉不到，它感觉就像是一个普通的常规应用。是的，我的意思是，你还会遇到另一个问题，那就是大多数像 Electron、Neutrino 这样的框架，它们运行的是一个 JavaScript 网页服务器。所以甚至连
And you can often... Your API often doesn't have to be that large. If you parameterize the things you're doing, you might not actually need that many function calls to get a lot done. Like, for example, you might have 30 different channels. If you leave any of them, it's the same function call, right? So you don't have to implement that a bunch of times.
服务器都是用 JavaScript 写的。这意味着，如果你的业务逻辑是用 C++ 编写的，那么你实际上需要第三个进程——你需要浏览器，需要托管 UI 的网页服务器，现在你还需要在第三个程序中运行业务逻辑，并且你必须进行进程间通信来传递数据。所以，例如在 Discord 中，你点击一个按钮——假设现在 Discord 可能全是用 JavaScript 写的，但我们假装它的业务逻辑是用 C++ 写的来做个解释——所以在 Discord 中你点击了一个按钮，浏览器就会向网页服务器发送一个 HTTP POST 请求，说“帕特里克点击了加入频道的按钮”。然后那个服务器会向 C++ 代码发起一个进程间通信调用，说“嘿，帕特里克点击了加入频道”。然后那个 C++ 代码可能会向某个 Discord 服务器发送另一个 HTTP 请求，实际完成这个操作。所以你会有很多这样的跳转。不过，别被这个吓到了。听起来可能有点吓人，比如“天哪，为了做任何事情，我都得设置这种三层的代码契约”。但作为交换，你所获得的力量是非常强大的。
Off of the sort of like single app stuff, I think we had a couple of good other things that sort of fall in the same category. As Jason kind of mentioned, I've never seen the numbers, but I would bet it's a shockingly high percentage of applications written are written for internal use, for tests, for with only in your, you know, just to support like use cases, or maybe they're even just throw away. And so I would not be surprised if actually we don't see that the sort of long lived examples we've been giving so far, because you know about them are actually relatively rare, even by amount of time spent, which would be weird. So of course, they're
而且通常情况下，你的 API 并不需要写得那么庞大。如果你将正在做的事情参数化，你可能实际上并不需要那么多的函数调用就能完成大量的工作。例如，你可能有 30 个不同的频道，但无论你离开哪一个，调用的都是同一个函数，对吧？所以你不需要重复实现很多次。
more rare by count. But I think I would even go to say like a lot of the developer time is spent on developing apps that no more than a handful of people or anyone outside the company has ever seen. And so if that's the case, you have a little bit more latitude to consider things for the same purposes I've been doing and doing sort of UI and interfaces and really helping like Jason was already showing like graphs and data. Sometimes you're just trying to provide visualization. And so your app really doesn't need a lot of business logic. Maybe you've already processed it all down and it really just needs to do analysis or monitoring or something at the tail end. And you can avoid a lot of the interprocess communication. And so if that's true, I would say your sort of field of view can open up pretty wide and you can start to consider other ways of developing user interfaces or even applications for internal use. Yeah, totally. Have you ever used Jupyter? I think it used to be called IPython Notebook. I have, but I famously am not a great Python person. So I always find it a little, the environment setup, making everything sure is installed but yes i i think you know bump
抛开这种单应用的内容不谈，我觉得我们还有其他几个属于同一类别的好东西。正如杰森所提到的，我从来没看过具体数据，但我敢打赌，有相当惊人高比例的应用程序是为了内部使用、测试、为了配合特定的用例而编写的，甚至可能只是一次性的。所以我不会感到惊讶，事实上我们所看到的这些长寿的例子（因为你了解它们）其实相对较少，哪怕按消耗的时间来算也是如此，这挺奇怪的。所以当然，按数量计算，它们
into them fairly often now and actually it's pretty convenient to have like code listed and then a result and then code listed and then a you know result uh is is very intuitive way of sharing somebody's analysis yeah totally i think you know google collab i think is really going to it's one of these things that's like it's going to take a generation. But but, you know, Google. So for people who don't know, Google Colab is a computing environment where Google will give you GPU time for free. So if you need a GPU to train like some image processing model or something, you could use Google Colab. And there are some limitations. I think if your program takes more than 24 hours to run, they shut it down, things like that.
会更稀少。但我想说的是，很大一部分开发人员的时间都花在了开发那些只有少数人或公司外部人员见过的应用上。如果情况确实如此，你就会有更多的自由度去考虑和我们刚才做的一样的事情，比如处理 UI 和界面，真正像杰森刚才展示的那样处理图表和数据。有时候，你只是想提供可视化功能，所以你的应用其实并不需要太多的业务逻辑。也许你已经把所有数据都处理完了，它只需要在最后阶段进行分析或监控之类的工作，这样你就可以避免大量的进程间通信。如果这是真的，我认为你的视野可以放得相当开，你可以开始考虑其他开发用户界面甚至内部应用的方法。是的，完全同意。你用过 Jupyter 吗？我想它以前叫 IPython Notebook。我用过，但我出名地不擅长 Python 语言。所以我总是觉得它有点……环境设置、确保所有东西都安装妥当……不过是的，我觉得你现在会经常碰到它们。而且说实话，有代码、然后是结果，再有代码、然后是结果，这种排版方式非常直观，是分享他人分析成果的一种极佳方式。是的，完全同意。我认为 Google Colab 真的将普及这一点。这是那种需要花上一代人时间才能普及的事情。但是，Google 提供的……对于那些不知道的人来说，Google Colab 是一个计算环境，Google 会免费为你提供 GPU 时间。所以如果你需要 GPU 来训练某些图像处理模型之类的东西，你可以使用 Google Colab。当然也有一些限制，我想如果你的程序运行时间超过 24 小时，他们就会把它关掉，诸如此类。
Now you can get around all those limitations by getting the pro version, which is only 10 bucks a month, which is, I think, very reasonable. But especially because a GPU probablypu probably costs like a hundred dollars a month if you were to run it uh hundreds of dollars a month if you were to run it 24 7 um but you know google collab i think will really popularize uh jupiter and ipython even more um than they have and as patrick said it's that environment's broken up into cells and you can uh the way it works is
现在你可以通过购买专业版来绕过所有这些限制，专业版每月只需 10 美元，我认为这非常合理。尤其是因为如果你自己去租一个 GPU，24 小时全天候运行的话，
that the last line of of each code block uh of each code cell is rendered right afterwards i mean you could also do prints and stuff like that and they'll show up but now you can do a bunch of math and then at the end say you know table as just its own line in the last line of the cell and and that tells you know jupiter notebook that oh okay when i'm done with computing this i want to print the table and it'll actually convert you know this like raw python data into like this beautiful html table or you know a plot or or other stuff so it's really neat um you know the the downside is it's very hard to actually show that to somebody else so you can give someone a google collab notebook and they can run it themselves but for example if you wanted to
每月大概要花上百美元、几百美元。不过，我认为 Google Colab 确实会使 Jupyter 和 IPython 变得比以往更加普及。正如帕特里克所说，那个环境被拆分成了多个代码单元格（cells），你可以……它的工作原理是，
just show the results to somebody there isn't really an easy way to do that. You kind of have to just copy it and paste it to someone. I think you can export as PDF or something, but at that point, it's not really an interactive user interface. So there is kind of a middle ground there called Streamlit. So Streamlit is also kind of much more geared to internal analysis so you know if you can plot time series and you can plot different graphs and do analysis but you couldn't for example make a video game and stream lit uh at least not easily um but you know it's another kind of good avenue to go down.
每个代码块、每个代码单元格的最后一行会在紧接着的地方被渲染出来。当然你也可以使用 print 之类的方法让它们显示出来，但现在你可以做一堆数学计算，然后在最后写上类似“table”作为单独的一行放在单元格的最后一行，这就告诉 Jupyter Notebook：“哦，好的，当我计算完这个之后，我想把这个表格打印出来。”它实际上会把这种原始的 Python 数据转换成漂亮的 HTML 表格、图表或其他内容。这真的很酷。缺点是，很难把这个直接展示给其他人。你可以把一个 Google Colab 笔记本给别人，让他们自己去运行，但例如，如果你只是想把结果展示给某人，并没有一个很简便的方法做到这一点。你基本上只能把它复制并粘贴给别人。我想你可以把它导出为 PDF 之类的，但到那个时候，它就不是一个真正可交互的用户界面了。所以这里其实有一个折中的方案，叫作 Streamlit。Streamlit 也是更偏向于内部分析的工具，所以你可以绘制时间序列、绘制各种图表并进行分析，但你不能在 Streamlit 中制作一个电子游戏——至少没那么容易。不过，这也是一条很不错的可行之路。
And I guess maybe we'll just cap it off by also putting Unity and Godot in these game engines. I think that in something like Godot or Unity, you have much more control over the user interface. You could be almost guaranteed it's going to look pixel for pixel exactly the same in every OS. It's got these advantages. And the clear disadvantages are you're working at the pixel level. So even a button, you literally have to draw the button.
我想最后我们也可以把 Unity 和 Godot 归入这些游戏引擎中。我认为在像 Godot 或 Unity 这样的引擎中，你对用户界面的控制要大得多。你可以几乎百分之百保证它在每个操作系统上都能做到像素级的完全一致。它有这些优势。而显而易见的缺点是，你是在像素级别进行操作的。所以甚至连一个按钮，你都必须字面意义上去绘制这个按钮。
And so some of these will have UI toolkkits but um even then it's very primitive like you know they won't have a pressed you know button image so um so that's pretty low level but uh for people who are doing a lot of like graphic intensive stuff that could be a good option at a high level i think uis are the, I think I alluded to it earlier, but just to kind of cap it off, are one of these things where you run into it. It's actually good to know how to do it. It's one of those perpetual, I should be better at doing this and being able to prop one open, pop something open quickly and sort of use for internal purposes. But there are some also, again, I think like next level understanding that people have to do, especially at least if you're coming from sort of, I'll say like Python
因此其中一些引擎会有 UI 工具包，但即便如此，它也非常原始，比如它们不会自带一个按下状态的按钮图片等。所以这属于相当底层的操作。但对于那些从事大量图形密集型工作的人来说，这可能是一个不错的选择。从宏观层面来看，我认为 UI 是那种——我刚才可能已经暗示过了，但为了总结一下——你会经常遇到的东西。实际上掌握它是很有用的。这是那种永远都在提醒自己“我应该在这方面做得更好一点”、“能够快速搭出一个界面用于内部目的”的技能。但同时，这也需要一些更深层次的理解，特别是如果你来自 Python、
or C++ or C or even Java, which is, you know, we're mentioning before is multi-threading, because like all this different stuff going on, you might have like a, you want to want to render a spinning box right like a little spinner to indicate your program is doing something but code needs to be running the spinner for the spinner to look smooth and so if you're going to be doing that you need to be doing your execution on something else and then the sort of like first thing is you go into one of these creators and you draw a button when you click the button you run your computation but of course then the button that's stuck, depressed, and your mouth is frozen. Everybody bumps into this early on.
C++、C 甚至是 Java 领域的话，就像我们之前提到的多线程问题。因为这里面有各种各样的事情在并发进行，你可能想要渲染一个旋转的方框——比如一个小转轮来表示你的程序正在执行某项任务。但是，为了让转轮看起来平滑，代码必须持续运行这个转轮动画。如果你要这样做，你就必须在其他地方执行你的计算任务。然后你遇到的第一件事就是：你进入这些设计器中画了一个按钮，当你点击按钮时，你运行了你的计算。但理所当然的，按钮卡在被按下的状态，你的鼠标也死机了。每个人早期都会碰到这个问题。
And I think the UI development tools themselves have gotten better about helping coach people into having a wizard where you already start off with, hey, when a button is clicked, it's going to dispatch a message and you need to wait that message over here and put the boilerplate code for you there to hint you know, hey, when a button is clicked, it's going to dispatch a message and you need to wait that message over here and sort of put the boilerplate code for you there to like hint you that like, hey, this is what you ought to be doing. But I think like this is one of the first
我想 UI 开发工具本身在引导开发者方面已经做得很好了，它们会提供一个向导，让你一开始就看到：嘿，当按钮被点击时，它会分发一条消息，你需要在这里等待该消息，并在那里为你放置好样板代码，以此提示你：嘿，这就是你应当做的事情。但我认为这也是人们容易遇到竞态条件（race conditions）的地方之一：嘿，我的代码正在处理，但有人点击了另一个按钮。所以你会看到那个最基本的原语，比如“开始计算”，然后它显示一些进度，“取消”。等等，等一下。我写过的绝大多数程序都没有取消当前正在进行的操作的选项。我的意思是，你只能强行杀死应用，对吧。它们没有那种在半途停下来的概念。
time people can run into race conditions where, hey, my code is processing, but someone clicked another button. So, you know, you see that basic primitive, like start computation, right? And then it's showing some progress. Cancel. Well, wait a minute. Most of the programs I've ever written didn't have an option to cancel what they were doing. I mean, you could kill the app. Right. They didn't have this notion of stopping halfway through.
你启动它们，要么它们报错，要么它们完成。它们没有一种机制去监听：“哦，实际上，我想让你停下正在做的事情。”所以我认为这是人们开始意识到需要进行深思熟虑的架构设计的地方之一。是的，这真的是一个非常非常好的观点。在移动端和网页端（在较小程度上），它们真的会手把手地教你。比如我知道在 iOS 和 Android 上，如果你在主线程上执行一些耗时超过几毫秒的操作，日志里就会弹出这个巨大的错误，说：
You start them and they either error out or they finish. They don't have a mechanism for listening for, oh, actually, I want you to stop what you're doing. And so I think this is one of the places where people start to bump into needing some thoughtful architecture. Yeah, that's a really, really good point. I mean, on mobile and web, to a lesser extent, they really hold your hand. Like I know iOS and Android, if you do something on the main thread that takes more than a few milliseconds, you know, it'll pop up this big error in your log saying,
“嘿，不要这样做。去把它放到另一个线程或其他地方。”而且我认为在这两个平台上，如果你试图在主线程上发起 HTTP 请求，它们会直接让你的应用崩溃。这是它们非常激进的一种表达方式，意思是：“听着，你需要搞懂线程机制以及所有这些东西，否则你甚至无法运行这个应用。”
hey, you know, don't do this. Like, go put this on another thread or something. And I think both of them, if you try to do an HTTP request on the main thread, they will just crash your app. And so it's their really aggressive way of saying, like, look, like you need to figure out threading and all that. Otherwise, you can't even run this app.
但在桌面上，却没有那么强烈的观点和限制。所以你必须在学习过程中踩很多这样的坑。但是，是的，我认为另一个非常重要的事情——这在各个方面都适用——就是一定要把你的 UI 和业务逻辑分离开来。例如，假设你有一个 Electron 应用，如果你以某种特定的方式架构这个应用，你可以启动 UI，而 UI 从你的 C++ 程序中获取其状态。如果你的业务逻辑中有一个 Bug（绝大多数 Bug 都会出现在这里），你就可以修复这个 Bug，而无需关闭应用并重新启动它。
But on the desktop, you know, there's it's just not that opinionated. And so you have to learn a lot of those along the way. But, yeah, I think another really important thing, and this is kind of true across the board, is really separate your ui and your business logic like for example let's say you have an electron app um you know if you if you architect the app in a certain way you know you could start up the ui and the ui is getting kind of its state from your c++ program. And if you have a bug in your business logic, which is where the vast majority of your bugs are going to be, you can fix that bug without having to shut down the app and bring it back up.
所以这是许多人没有意识到的一点：启动一个应用需要很长时间。在移动端、桌面上，你会谈论好几秒钟的时间——启动一个应用需要很长时间，在移动端和桌面上，启动一个应用需要好几秒钟，哪怕只是为了展示一个“Hello World”。操作系统在底层做了各种疯狂的事情，通常会有一个视觉效果，比如应用窗口凭空弹出。所有这些都是需要时间的。虽然听起来时间不多，但积少成多，累积起来非常可观。所以你可以绕过很多这样的时间消耗。而且即使不仅仅是时间问题，作为开发者也会感到很沮丧：“哦，我漏了一个冒号，现在我必须点击 UI 上的 X 键并重新启动，诸如此类。”所以通过一些聪明的架构设计，你可以轻松地
So this is one thing a lot of people don't realize is starting an app takes a long time. On mobile, on desktop, you're talking like multiple you know starting an app takes a long time you know on mobile on desktop like you're talking like multiple seconds to start an app um just to like get hello world i just os is doing all sorts of crazy stuff under the hood you know there's usually like a visual like the app kind of window pops up out of nowhere all of that you know it takes time and while it doesn't sound like a lot of time, it really, really adds up. So you can get around a lot of that. And even if it's not just a time thing, it is frustrating as a developer. Like, oh, I forgot a colon. Now I have to click the X on the UI and start it up again and blah, blah, blah. And so you could easily,
做到这一点。通过一些聪明的架构设计，你可以轻松地让自己处于这样一种状态：这两个部分是独立运行的，其中一个知道——你可以从你的业务逻辑进程向你的 UI 逻辑进程发送一条消息，说“嘿，我回来了，我刚才崩溃了又恢复了，这是崭新的我”。然后你的 UI 就会知道该如何清除所有内容并重新开始，而不必真正销毁所有的图形元素。所以，我也绝对犯过这样的错误：我没有以这种方式设计架构，结果发现自己每一次修改都要花上 30、40、50 秒来进行
it's some clever architecture, you could easily you know it's some clever architecture you could easily get into a position where you know those two are running independently and one of them knows like you can send a message from your business logic process to your ui logic to ui process saying hey you know i'm back like i died and i came back and this is new me and then your ui knows to like clear everything and start over without having to actually tear down all of the graphical elements so so um i've definitely been guilty of this where um you know i didn't architect things this way and then um you found myself taking 30, 40, 50 seconds to
迭代，这很容易让自己感到沮丧。好吧，非常感谢所有继续支持我们的 Patreon 赞助者，以及所有的听众。我想我们每一期节目都会说，节目能持续这么久真是太疯狂了。总之，谢谢大家一直以来的坚持。
do every single iteration and you can easily kind of get yourself frustrated. All right. Well, thank you to all our Patreons continuing to help support us and just everyone listening and I think we say it every episode, but it's been crazy how long it's been going. But, you know, thank you all for sticking with it.
如果你是新听众，欢迎加入。我们没有准备那种正式的推介词，不过你可以查看我们的网站。上面有一些链接可以关注，如果你想了解更多或听更多内容的话。但总的来说，感谢社区给予我们的所有支持和厚爱。是的，完全同意。我在我的个人邮箱和 Programming Throwdown 邮箱中收到了很多积极的反馈——顺便厚着脸皮宣传一下，邮箱是 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com——大家都提到很喜欢双人主持的节目，很喜欢我们把这种形式重新带回来，这真的很棒。能够与大家分享我们的经历，真的是一件非常荣幸的事情。而且，嗯，虽然这算是个题外话，但有很多播客在 2019 到 2020 年左右就夭折了。其实我之前有一个想要重新拾起来的游戏开发播客，
Or if you're new, welcome. We don't have that pitch, but you can check out the website. You do have some links there to follow, but also if you want to learn more or hear more. But just in general, thanks for all the support and love we get from the community. Yeah, totally. I've been getting a lot of positive feedback in my personal email and the programming throwdown email which just shameless plug is programming throwdown at gmail.com um about how people like the duo episodes they like how we're bringing those back which is great um you know it is um you know real pleasure to be able to share our experiences with everybody and uh um yeah and i you know this is kind of an aside but um so many podcasts uh perished around like 2019 2020 i was actually um there was a game development podcast that i wanted to get back to
但他们停止更新了。我刚好在 LinkedIn 上和那个主持人有联系，所以我在 LinkedIn 上给他发了消息，问他：“嘿，发生什么事了？”他说：“哦，我觉得内容已经差不多够了，诸如此类。”
and uh you know they stopped making episodes and i just happened to be connected on linkedin to the host so i messaged him on linkedin i said hey you know what happened and he said well um you know i think that there's just enough out there or something like that and and you know, I think that there's just enough out there or something like that. And, and, you know, people want to move on to other things. Um, but you know, I think it's, it's, uh, really proud that, you know, the two of us have been able to, uh, keep this going for so long and we have no intention of stopping, uh, making good content. So that was a, that was a bit of a cliffhanger there. Like you're leading up to something, but yeah, this is a, this is actually just clickbait. Yeah. We're not going anywhere. We should make the, we should make the thumbnail.
而且，“我觉得内容已经差不多够了，大家也想转向其他事情了。”但是，你知道的，我真的很骄傲我们两个能够把这个节目坚持这么久，而且我们完全没有停下制作优质内容的打算。所以刚才那算是一个小悬念，好像你要引出什么重大事情一样。但其实这只是一个标题党（clickbait）。是的，我们哪儿也不去。我们应该把封面图做成……
Yeah. Like we're, we're leaving. If we were, if we were really optimizing for SEO thumbnail, we're leaving our house to go get dinner. That's right. Uh, but yeah, thanks again for all the folks. We have people have been patrons for years and years. We really appreciate it. Um, all of your support.
对，就像我们要离开一样。如果我们真的在为 SEO 和缩略图做优化的话，那就是：我们要离开家去吃晚饭了。没错。不过，再次感谢所有一直以来的朋友。有很多人连续多年成为我们的 Patreon 赞助者，我们真的非常感激你们所有的支持。
And we will catch y'all in a couple weeks. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们会在几周后与大家再次见面。片头/片尾音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，以及进行重混和改编，但您必须按照原作者的要求署名帕特里克和我，并以相同方式分享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。